It's really bizarre for a full minute, no one can hear me, but then it's fine, I don't
know.
It's rather bizarre.
Rather bizarre indeed.
Oh my God, I got so many comments on my YouTube.
Hold on a minute.
It's just so over for the moment.
I'm spilling.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
The frickin' Reflins joined membership.
Hold on a minute.
Link322 and Stalkin.
Thank you for the memberships.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Can you guys finally see me?
Is it going to register that you guys can see?
Oh thank goodness.
It takes so long for that, right?
Reflins, Reflins, Reflins.
I know normally at any minute we're throwing fists, we're fighting.
I have a very serious, very incredibly.
This is life or death for my channel.
I'm not being funny.
What pose?
What pose do you want me pregnant with you?
What pose do you want to be in my tummy in?
This is life or death.
Life or death for this channel.
This channel will pivot and not survive if we do not do this.
Hold on.
I'm opening up a poll.
Hold the phone.
I'm opening up a poll as we speak.
I will change the thumbnail soon TM, but it is so important.
Hold on.
Poll.
Start poll.
What pose for you in my tum tum in my tum tum?
As I spelled that terribly wrong, tum tum.
Pose one.
Pose two.
That's right.
Don't ever say.
Don't ever say you don't eat well at VEAL or headquarters.
I don't want to hear it.
How am I making this worse?
Literally, you decide the fate of my channel with this one pose alone.
Go.
What pose for you in my tum tum?
You must vote.
Four.
Phil Nelson.
I mean, your technicals can be extended, but the Phil Nelson.
You get too early to do the poll.
More people need to join the stream.
I mean, I stream every single time, at the same time every day.
Bar one day before anyone's like,
Actually, you were the last bell to stream.
You were two hours late.
Actually, no.
I was doing a meeting and everyone's happy and the marshmallows are coming back.
So if you want to send any nice marshmallows to the girls, please be my guest.
Be my guest.
My guest.
You're welcome to be my guest.
Let's see.
This is what you're drinking.
Cola.
Oh, it's cola.
Wait, is it vote?
Whoa, we have a unanimous, unanimous vote of pose three.
I will relay that to the artist as we speak.
The reeflings have kindly decided that pose three is the most voted for by far.
I would love to see that pose further developed for this commission.
Thank you so much for working so quickly.
Because I didn't realise I was going to get an update so quickly on these options.
I didn't even know I was going to get options.
I sent away a little reference sheet.
Do you want to see the reference sheet?
It's pretty funny.
Right, sorry.
The reeflings have kindly decided that pose three is the most voted for by far.
I would love to see that pose further developed in this commission.
Thank you so much for working on these options and giving me choices.
This has been a fantastic experience so far.
I am very lucky to have found you as an artist.
And before anyone's like, oh, your voice sounds sarcastic when you're typing that.
No, I mean it.
This is what I sent away.
I did not expect at all to get...
Hold on, so that's the image there.
I did not at all expect to get opportunities to even pick a pose further than what I had submitted.
Where the fuck is the image that I just saved?
Oh no. Where is it?
Hold on a minute.
Save image as on desktop is...
It's on the desktop. I can see it when I go to save it again.
There we go.
This is what I sent away the reference as.
This is what...
How else end that pose?
Good morning.
That's what I sent away.
Come on, don't laugh.
I was like, oh come on, got my little reefling.
We got our little placenta line going.
So placenta actually attaches...
I think the placenta sits at any part of the wall in theory.
It can go anywhere.
And I was like, did we put it at the top of the womb?
And I was like, you know what?
No, it can attach at any point.
So we'll just do a straight line coming from my wee reefling.
But yeah, that's the reference I sent away.
And then they very, very kindly gave us those four options.
Those three options, pardon.
And then, yeah, you guys picked three.
So I'm gonna be pregnant with you.
Are you ready to be in my tummy?
I was gonna write the script together.
And then I can say all the adorable things.
I also caught up with my dad and told him how awesome you guys are.
And I was like, dad, guess who played Microsoft?
And he was like, shut the front door.
And I was like, hell, yeah, I didn't.
And I told, I was like, I was telling him about how you used to absolutely wreck and deck.
Also, apparently our Canadian pot smoker isn't called grizzle.
It's gristle. Oops.
So it's gristle.
If you're out there, one Canadian gristle.
Sorry, I've got your gamer tag wrong.
My dad was, oh, he should have seen the disgust on his face when I was like,
oh, I gave a shout out to gristle and everything.
And he was, oh, oh, wrong gamer tag.
Oh, sorry. I wasn't even like two years old at this point.
Like, oh, sorry.
Close enough.
Did you tell him we're getting top seven?
He was laughing at that so hard.
He was like, wait, because no one submitted for it.
And I was like, yeah, because it's such an old game.
But I told him we made VTuber history because I'm the first VTuber to play Microsoft.
Like 99.9% sure.
Unless there's some obscure person hidden in the YouTube algorithm,
we made VTuber history by being the first person to play Microsoft.
So, feels good, man.
I also told them that I've not submitted my note.
I should though, just for the hell of it.
Fuck it. I will. I will. I'll do it after the stream because this is a cool downstream.
If you didn't know, we're not actually playing
Cooking Simulator
or Women Simulator, whatever you want to call it, your choice.
I may or may not be absolutely distraught.
I'm actually going to update the stream thumbnail right now
because I think people generally think I'm sitting on...
Oh, if you heard that.
Oh, my PC didn't like that.
Right, let's pop away the pregnancy for now.
Because I've got something else I want to show you.
Because the streams start coming and they don't stop coming
and the streams start coming and they don't stop coming
and they beg to the room and they hit the ground running.
Didn't make sense not to stretch the bandwidth
because we keep on gaming, but we keep on gaming.
So much to do, so much to see, so much to game, so much to do, so much to game.
Mate, the name of this stream is going to be recovering from
John Wick for Wiccamba.
Remember that time? Do you remember what happened yesterday?
Yeah, I remember. I still remember.
Very vividly what happened.
Not to be confused with vividly, oh, some more, the streamer.
Okay, that should update.
I hope it has felt cultural, right?
Yes, we are going to start the GamerScore grind.
So, things are going to...
We're going to start doing the Xbox GamerScore grind,
starting off with Cameo.
Now, I know we've still got Binding of Isaac tomorrow
and a membership stream of Iron Man.
Guinness, I'm not going to greet during that.
My eyes are still puffy.
Those window noises jump-scared me.
I'm sorry, it was me, it was me.
My PC doesn't like when I download an image for some reason.
It gets all up its arse.
Honestly, it gets its wee panties and leaves in the cliffs
and I'm like, hmm, it needs to be with me.
But yes, we're going to try Stray.
Apparently, it's five hours long.
Cameo is roughly eight hours split,
so I'm going to try and be a bit easier on myself
with these endurance streams,
especially because there's a few things...
Oh, a secret.
Thank you for the five gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with their face.
Make sure to interact with chat
because I think there's a prompt that says
to accept GIFs on channels for some reason.
It just doesn't happen automatically.
I don't know.
But, yes, what am I doing?
Oh my God, it's officially...
Hold on, wait.
I might even have a further thing to show you
if I have it, if it's lurking in the shadows.
Yes, there is...
Oh, I do have it, I do have it.
Okay, you might hear the windows sound.
It's my computer, not yours.
It's my computer.
Okay, it's my computer.
One last thing to show you,
and then we'll get Gambon to make myself feel better.
Wow, I've spoken like a true addict.
Holy crap.
It has been...
Why is it locked?
Unlock yourself right now.
It has been almost one month of streams,
and here we are, a little refluence.
Here we are.
Can you tell?
I like streaming, question mark.
I'll swap out the runescape key.
But it's been one month.
I'm going to tweet this out.
I'm going to tweet it out with my YouTube statistics
and just be like, thank you for anyone
and everyone who interacted with me.
It has been nothing short of a complete pleasure
to be able to do this.
Nothing short of a complete pleasure,
pure happiness, pure, pure vibes,
whatever you want to call it.
It has been nothing but fantastic.
I'm very happy.
Those are all the streams.
I will swap out the part five for my new one
because technically I didn't do the part five runescape.
But yes, we are in, please do not be mistaken
in thinking that, oh no, it's going to slow down now.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Mommy built different.
I can't believe it's already been a dad stream
more than some streamers in a year, be honest.
Hold on, let me take a drink of cola
and then let me finish off my tea.
But yes, I have had an absolutely fantastic month.
I'm sure all the girls will absolutely agree
and say we've had just beyond immeasurable
happiness success.
When I go off of stream, like once I finish this stream,
everyone's debut highlights are going up as well.
I'm going to put some advertising money back
and behind it as well just to help the girls out
with their growth because I've got a goal
for them to achieve this month
and obviously I need to enable them.
I need to enable their human, I was going to say
I was going to say humidities
for the implication of cookies.
I don't know why.
It only goes even faster from here.
The second thumbnail exposing VLR.
Oh, did you like it?
Thanks, I made it myself.
I'm just so good.
I'm just so MLG Pro, honestly.
Oh, that's my game capture, please don't.
Wait, my game capture is in mine.
It's because I'm dumb.
But yes, it's been a fantastic month.
Next month, I'm going to be pregnant with you in my belly.
Next month, my...
Right, actually hold on, hold on, let's discuss this.
While we're busy fighting and off all the time,
I actually do need to discuss the length of streams
coming up in Dru...
Where the frick?
I now have two of these.
Am I okay?
I don't think so.
Okay, well, if it's that one,
right, we need to discuss
or we need to bring about.
So my dad's coming over, I'm not hitting the fact.
My dad's coming.
My dad's coming to see me.
So, why does time go faster every year?
Isn't that not like a relatively...
Fainting the finished Elden Ring DLC?
Oh yeah, you're going to carry me later when we play it again.
I've never played Spiral.
I think I might have played it as a child,
but I do not remember it.
I think maybe my dad played it, but even he said,
like, I'm not even sure about that.
And I'm like, maybe I just made it up
and watched people play it as a child.
Your dad, yeah, you're going to meet your father-in-law.
I'm not sure.
I might bring him on stream for like five seconds,
but all you're going to hear is
for the love of effing God.
Do not say my legal name, my name is Strani.
Okay, don't say anything.
And he'll be like, hi, Radish boys.
And I'm like, no, they're called Raeflings, dad!
Raeflings!
Mail on stream.
Oh, for fuck's sake.
Then he start mail on stream if it's my dad.
I will fucking have a riot.
If someone fucking goes mail on stream,
drop, because my fucking dad shows up on stream.
Oh my God, I'm fighting phantoms right now.
I'm ready to swing on my chair.
I'm fighting phantoms.
Lou phantoms dans ma chambre.
Chambre, fuck.
Man, I'm such a fake Frenchie.
New nickname, we're Radish boys.
It was your old nickname.
It was your old nickname
when you were in the cryo pod,
but now you're called Raeflings, r-e-e-e-e.
Raeflings.
Already fighting them visibly,
but literally the phantom's in my room right now.
The phantom's dans ma chambre,
in my room, in my bedroom,
and to be specific.
Mmm.
Yes, but for the next
three weeks,
ash,
there's not going to be too many
endurance streams, because
so my dad said the first few days
he's going to not even be
on the same time zone.
I don't even know if he's going to be awake.
He's probably going to be awake while I'm streaming.
Oh my God, oh he's going to be here
and has like all our ridiculous conversations.
Um, but it's fine.
It's fine.
My dad laughs
and he finds it funny.
You can just pre-record a segment.
Probably. The phantom's have got
to fight my mental illness.
Bro, I'm pheromone maxing right now.
I'm fucking disgusting. I'm so greasy.
I smell V.O.
I was going to have a shower
after John went.
Uh, the reason why I don't have any news
other than what I've just shown
is because I did nothing yesterday
after the stream. I was so distraught.
I was so distraught. I didn't have
a shower. I went to bed.
I had a nap. I woke up.
I ended up binging to
TikTok for four hours.
Um, I'm literally pheromone maxing
right now and then I went back to sleep
because I felt so bad after
watching that film.
Uh,
so let's just say no emotional
films. No films I have any
emotional little
things.
Literally I didn't even eat. I've still not eaten
since I had the past, was it
pasta? Left over pasta with you
yesterday. On Rinscape
that's the last time I've eaten because I've
been so distraught.
I'm such a cry baby.
I can't even eat.
Um,
no I'm not even hungry. That's the thing.
Thank you Jake Norman for coming
out. Member!
Uh, our membership streams for the week.
Classic script writing. You guys are going to tell me what you want to hear again.
We're going to do a
the plot has already been picked out slightly.
Um, it's going to be a choose your own
adventure kind of plot.
But we will be
publicly writing
ASMR collabs with
VR.
I have five one-on-one collabs planned
with the girls. I'm not even told the girls yet.
Uh, I'm just doing it. I'm just bombing into their DMs
being like hey, how's it going?
Actually, out of raw
curiosity did that Rinscape stream
get limited ads for
the language I was using
because there was no in-game audio or voices.
Wow!
My John Wick stream was fine.
I literally constantly went
and said
pretty
pretty outrageous stuff.
Not going to lie.
The banks were mentioned at one point
and then the banks became the high table.
So from now on
the high table is how we
reference the banks, okay?
Um,
eat when you're ready and hungry.
Yeah.
I'm fine. No, no, that's fine.
She's sad girl Maxine for real, for real.
Um, if you
didn't make it for yesterday's stream
um,
I want to say John Wick
spoilers.
Maybe?
Uh, is it for the first 30 minutes
you're not allowed to say anything bad? Well, I'm pretty sure
like I was just straight out coming out
with the sentences like we should be
where the banks and stuff and I'm like
hold on a minute, isn't usually going to have problems
with us?
Yeah, I think I know.
I'm going to finish that
in the movie. I had to put, oh.
Okay, I'm not spoiling nothing.
If you've not watched John Wick
if you've not
watched John Wick, you're welcome to watch me
um, create
Wines whilst watching the movie.
Um, do not whatever you do
up to the end of the VOD
for any reason, even though
the movie isn't displayed in the stream
uh, you'll be able to hear in my voice
what happened.
Uh, should know. Don't, don't do that.
Don't do that. Uh, yes. So there's going to be
a few shorter streams but
with these shorter streams that are coming up in
July there's going to be a lot more
consistency, I repeat a lot more
consistency with ASMR uploads.
So it's like a reward
less mummy equals more mummy
more mummy equals less mummy.
Yeah?
That makes sense.
There's the, there's more of me.
There's, okay, this, I don't know
why this didn't pop, but here we go.
Re-roll the shop a total of
100 times and we've got Re-rolls
cost 2 bucks left. Didn't we not already have
that?
Play a total of 300. Wait, why is
this popping now? Re-face
all, uh
Re-triggers all played face cards.
That's a curious one.
That could be used in combination.
Spend a total of 2.5 in the shops.
Woah!
One extra card slot
available in the shop. That's curious.
It doesn't make sense, but more mummy
means more happy. Yes, there's a
few things I wish to execute this month.
Wow, uh, as an
execute plans, not as an execute
the high table.
Um,
planets appear 4 times more
likely. Buy a total.
Okay. Wow!
Jeez, Louise!
First thing in the morning
you want to do that to me? Right.
Dev's getting a message right now.
Dev's getting a message. Continue!
Oh, uh, I think
this is, uh, yeah, we've got our token.
We've got our token.
Um, we won, we won, we won.
That's the main thing. Okay.
Well, actually, I've got a f***ing force behind me.
So today we're having an easy day.
When I get off stream, all the girls are going to have
highlights, um,
uploaded, debut highlights
uploaded to their channel.
I'm also going to put some advertisement in it.
Uh, I'm not putting any advertisement
in me. This is actually just straight up
internal veiler.
This is just straight up veiler
internal communications.
I don't put advertisements on my content,
but I put it on the girls' content
because I want to push them, not me.
This is just straight up comms. I need to shut the f*** up.
I'm, like, literally, uh,
a nightmare. Hold on. I did not
read what this
pack had. Hold on.
Oh no, what's
going with my Wii game?
Have I broken it?
Oh no.
Prevents death of chip scored
are at least 24 of the required.
It's just still...
Oh wow.
What's...
Okay, I think it's having a wee
melty, but that's okay. You're looking to have a melty.
Yo, look, it's
shiny. Just shows her backdoor,
honestly. Tire cards appear four times more
frequently. Okay.
Discover 25 blinds.
Okay. Re-roll boss blinds.
Unlimited times. Okay, okay.
Right, um, I'm actually going to have
to exit this run,
uh, because I didn't pay attention to what
the deck was. Hold on. Let's check...
Let's check out the deck rolls.
New run. At
end of each round, $2
per remaining hand,
$1 per discard, so
no interest. So there's no point in holding
on to economy on the green deck.
Curious.
Initial cards and booster packs are
free. That could definitely
throw us ahead quite
quite
a lot.
That's going to throw us ahead quite a lot, so
I'm going to take it, because we are... was it
10, 9, 8, 7, 6
straight.
Well, if the girl succeeds, you succeed. Yes.
I...
I've kind of touched up on this.
I have done everything I want to
do. Um,
I'm just happy to be back. I'm happy to be
making content, following my goofy ideas.
I mean, like, hell, who the fuck thinks
of pregnancy ASMR?
Um, like,
I just want to do that kind of stuff.
Like, that's where my focus is.
And making, like, funny shorts
and having a good time. Like, that's
where it's... that's what it's
all about. Earn a dollar for each
nine in your full deck. That's so specific.
Right, two booster cards.
What's the dealio? What's the dealio?
A straight...
What?
Four plus multiplier
for each card.
Below?
What does that mean?
So...
So, I can't use that one.
Uh...
If I play a straight... I mean...
You want
to cut cards. It's good for a thin deck.
Yeah, you got a thin deck.
Yeah, that joker is in...
Um, removing cards is actually
good.
I don't have death, though.
I don't know, maybe three
times multiplier for a straight, though.
I think if we could grab
that voucher that has
the...
one, two, skip a few.
I want one, two,
skip a few.
Yeah.
Reminder, there's no point
of holding on to economy. I'm sure
I just... three times multiplier
is insane.
Oh wait, multiplier at the end?
Well, not that the rest even affect it.
Yeah,
simplifying your deck for consistency
is a way for a better run. Me who just
fucking picked that order. Okay,
well, I've done it now.
The pillar, cards played previously
or debuff, that's fine.
Right, a straight.
An ace,
a king, a queen, a jack
and a ten.
Oh my god, what?
That's so weird.
Oh, you just do that then
and throw away the ace.
You're going for
straights during Pride Month?
Damn straight ass.
That's terrible. Don't laugh at that.
That's terrible.
Kings and queens.
Full house, kings and queens.
Okay.
That was a joke, by the way. Relax
snowflake, it's called humor.
Relax.
Okay, the straights aren't going very well.
What do you do?
Bakes?
Right, let's try and get
a few...
Let me get a few high
high straights.
Wait, what's a straight again?
It's when it goes one, two, three, four.
Five. Yeah, because when it's a flush
it's all the same color. Yeah, okay.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Hi, thank you for joining.
Thank you for anyone for showing up.
I do understand that I stream a bit extreme.
I stream a bit extreme.
I don't know, do we just... how much should we go?
320 blazer.
I mean, we could just get rid of these
and then throw that four away
and see what happens.
I think we're going to make it. Hold on, how much money do we get?
I have made a great
human error.
Oh lord, I have made a great
What do I need? A queen? I only have
one more queen in the deck.
I have made
a great error.
What do I need? A
10 and a queen.
That's an eight and a six.
Wait, so I need a seven. What are seven?
Okay, the odds of me pulling a seven are so high.
Nine, seven, eight,
six, five.
Discard and pray.
Oh my god, I've completely messed up.
I have to get rid of this.
I'm sorry, I do.
I have to get rid of the high.
I don't have much highs. The odds of
I was going to say the odds of highs are so rubbish.
Okay, 10, nine,
eight, seven, six,
zero.
Okay. That was pure
probability. That was pure probability.
Please, can we get the Joker that does that
thing where it does the thing?
That would be great.
Okay, we are going to...
Oh, that's not bad.
That's not bad. Retriggers all face cards.
So if I happen to get a flush with a face,
a target card and three playing
cards.
Forget, forget.
Something's better than nothing at this stage.
Okay, let's go next.
Oh, a Joker slot.
I'm in.
When they do it like this, it gets so tricky.
And then hope for a king and a tent to come flying
back into my hands.
Surely. Hydration check.
How do we call them?
Surprised you didn't go for the two, three, four and five.
I was feeling quirky. Okay.
It was, I was feeling quirky.
I got a fill house.
Wait, what's the fill...
Oh, you want me to go for fill house?
Fuck it.
Okay, but we're not going to get a flush from doing this.
How much do we get?
Sugar.
King, queen, jack.
So what, ten and nine?
Or seven, six, five.
Oh my gosh.
Just completely re-roll.
I'm going to fail.
I've got three hands.
Wait, I've only made a third.
No, we're going to have to start discarding
for a royal flush.
A royal straight.
Oh, don't do this to me now, game.
Unless I play a double here,
like double jack and double king.
The video lore girls get a little quirky at night.
More like being cheeky and nearly got clapped
for literally the first game in
and absolutely wrecking myself.
Okay, that's exactly what I was hoping for.
Let's go.
A straight. Let's go.
And it gets to play again on the big boys.
Okay.
Looks like I want everything to be royal.
Cloud nine gave us a cheeky four bucks
on top as well, remaining discards.
Yeah? Okay.
Whoa, who are you?
At first hand, a round is a single six.
Destroy it to create a spectral card.
Sure, you're free.
I'll take you.
Right.
We're investing in straights.
Which is...
Ah, not here.
Lucky me. It's not here.
Because why would it be here?
A straight flush?
That's so unlikely. Sorry.
I don't know who ever...
I don't know why you would play for that.
Unless like you maybe got some spectral packs
that like completely...
Uranis?
Fine, I picked Uranis.
I'm not like the other cuttlefish.
I get clapped.
I get clapped for my mistakes in Vulture.
Choose one of up to three turrets.
Hmm...
It's not looking good.
I'm needing something a bit better.
I'm not like other steamers.
I get clapped at the convention
by the replays.
What the fuck? I need to stop.
I need to stop. That was terrible.
Discard to re...
Also me, I wonder why we got uninvited
from that one convention?
Discard to random cards in the played hand.
That's fine.
Oh no, it's not because I'm going for straights.
And a played hand
Queen yep, yep, okay straight show me how you work
Okay, okay, okay, let him get up let him get up
So we just need a ten which we have three remaining odds of ten or high
Which we have three remaining odds of ten or high
Okay, there we go. That's all we needed
I need the card that lets you jump yes
We found it the other day, but we we had already maxed out on pairs should have to all my pairs
um
Earned four bucks or an extra discard
I mean
Four bucks
We'll grab voucher first clearance sale not we uh, I have one space remaining
Got a dip best of luck always risk the big play thank you
I'm wondering if we should get rid of eight ball for an extra discard because if we're going for straights
We need to be able to throw stuff away
I'm sorry if that's the wrong move, but it's my dumb move to make okay. Never gonna upgrade streets
Oh Saturn is a straight Saturn yes
And ring ring uh, you know what fuck it. Let's go for a turret. There's no such thing as interest so oh
We can do Saturn again
Absolutely, absolutely and you come right that worked out very well
Uh next base shop joker is
Polychrome and 1.5 multiplier. That's definitely worth it. I think I think let's find out
Discard is good for finding straights it is i'm
I
Know it's very painful doing it like this, but if we get a high flush this uh, whoever it is. Where are you?
If first hand of round is a single six
Destroy it. No, I don't have a six
um
Yeah, this times three and we just levelled up straight. So we'll go for a royal. I know it looks crazy
I know it looks absolutely
Terrible thrown away, but are you joking me right now?
Are you serious
Are we hello
Hello
This game has nothing but the audacity
Are you kidding me right now?
I literally
Five discards and I couldn't get a high card and the queen still hasn't shown up. I think I might have just thrown that
Because all we needed was a high flush. I threw everything I had five discards for a high flush
Nine eight seven six five. Oh well. We need pray that this is going to do some work
Are you kidding me?
Okay, thank goodness. Are you joking? You could have played the six
Eats. I need to jump. Whoa, who are you?
Okay, I will use you
Um, right. I'm going to keep the extra discard. Uh, I guess
You're in a dollar for each nine and no air and just straight up four bucks. Wait, who?
Oh, these are the exact same right get rid of you and you come. Yeah, you go to the right
You'll do your thing. All right, and then we're doing tariffs. Okay, tarot tarot card
little wild card
multipliers, I think we're gonna have to ask
Let's do this
Here we go. Here we go and you come and you come
The hybrophant the planet
Left to right. Okay, we're gonna take a low and make it a queen now
The left card turns into the right card
We're gonna really try and max up on the high straights
create tarot card
If poker hand contains an ace and a straight
That is ridiculously difficult so
Um, no, I'm gonna keep my economy for now. I know there's no interest
Oh, maybe I shouldn't must play five cards. Don't have to tell me twice
10 9 8 7 6 5
Mmm
It honestly looks like I have a better chance of doing low
Drop play the six
An ace two three four five equals a straight
Oh wait, hold on play the six play the six pause the dunes a first hand of round is a single six destroy it
Destroy it
Destroy it to create a spectral card. Does that mean discard?
If first hand of round is a single six destroy it
Motherfucker
What did that mean destroy it are you from here?
I said destroy it
The first hand not the first discard a folk sick
It's too early in the morning for this. Hold on right king queen. Oh my god. Never get all the royals are coming out
Oh, we need a jack then
We would need a jack to go either way a jack or a ace
I said a jack
Or an ace
Okay, ace king queen jack ten
I don't know why this game doesn't like me. I'm just trying my oh, I've got 14k for that. Okay that popped off
We're gonna be definitely investing in turrets. I'm gonna reroll. What are you rerolls cost two bucks less
You'll never guess what I want you
Iron five bucks for every four discards rank
changes
no
Game if you play astray. I mean that does compliment me
I'll destroy the six so there'll be new sixes. Oh, I get it now
Right turret cartoon
The chariot
Enhances the steel
converts the diamond a wild cat
Uh destroy up to two selected cards. Did we destroy low?
No
maybe
Three three four four four and four
I've got two. Oh, but that's a seven. It's like smack bang in the middle of the deck. It's not even lower numbers
Yeah, they're not they're not low enough spades steel. The best I got is a steel card steel card
How many who's who have I got the most of
A queen's the t-stat clea. I'm gonna oh wait both these queens are already special. Um, it's a wild card
Can't be used in any suit. No
You want the six to spectral you want the six?
It's turned into a steel. Are you on the ace to be a steel? I've got extra uses
I do
Didn't see this is why you guys are better playing this game than me because you guys spot stuff. I never look at
I'm like, oh, oh, I can't see it. What are you talking about recently?
What are you talking about right glass? I don't like glass because I don't want it to break
It increases the rank of two selected cards. I absolutely believe that's probably the best
Thing to utilize so
Oh, let's make a few things higher nine
Nine and eight let's bring it them up
I know I want things to be closer to a face card, but I don't want to completely negate the 10
Maybe eight and seven
Keep the nine
Eight and seven kind of push the deck higher
We've got two lore here and we want to push the deck upwards so we're more likely to roll higher
I don't know if that logic prevails though, but you know, you can push the four up what just four and
I guess make a nine
You're right. You're right. Make it higher. Make it higher. Make it higher
Right. No, no make the lures higher that will make it prevail. Okay. I might have made a mistake
But you know what I tried we roll. Wow. What are you?
You're cool, but I don't need you
Uh, we're just gonna buy that to use it because we get multiplier up every time we use uh
Thingy my barber discard
Gives a copy of the next like to tag
Lose the dollar pair around plate. Uh, I hope not
Rude I need an extra hand that would actually really come in clutch. I'm not gonna lie right everyone
Get used
Plot plop plop. Okay currently plus seven
Six solo six solo play
Race creates a random joker, but sets money to zero. Okay. We'll spend everything next round and use that
Mm-hmm
Wait, why did I get an oh got an any any from that? Okay, so what nine eight seven six five? We need a seven
I really don't want to start
Oh my gosh
Our dad just go for high
I'm just gonna go for high because we have a retrigger face
Play and just the six. Yes. Thank you. I'm I really do elevate everyone part
This game loves trolling me
Surely I'll draw a ten surely
Okay, ace king queen jack ten go
Okay, okay, okay. Okay. That was 15. Let's right. How do I use rate?
Sets your money to zero right. We're gonna spend all on purpose
Doubles money buy and use
Up you go. Lovely. Lovely
Cheeky planets, please give me saturn
Level up straight. Yes, please
Okay, nice nice
Uh, and then three of a kind high card full house
Um
I guess full house doesn't really do anything for me. Um, right. What are you?
Say it's your money to zero, but I can't utilize it. Hmm
I could probably use it now. Oh, I have made a grave error. I'm about to lose 37 dollars
oops
I'm using all my money then buys a car that doubles her money. Uh, I was gonna reroll
Ten wait, what am I doing? Add a negative joker, but take away your hand size. No, I'm already struggling with my hand size
For absolutely no reason your voice activated my phone and it was taken notice. Lovely. Lovely. Monka is
Monka is forget mind controlling you and mind controlling your technology add a gold seal to one slight card
That's probably
You don't have enough room for the joker. Anyway, you need to sell a joker to utilize that. Yeah
I'm not gonna lessen my hand size. I'm already struggling to get like a straight
Um
When plates so I guess you
Okay, and we're gonna reroll I've already had you guys and we're gonna reroll
And now reroll okay you buy and use
Did I just get rid of it?
Did I just sell this uh like I know it's race and like oh race big, but I'm just like oh should bet
Creates a rear joker
One extra discard extra money
Just buy don't use
Either sell a joker or sell race make a choice
So this is complimentary to my high that
A
Spectral card and it's adding a slot. So really
The only guy I can get rid of ah fuck it. We're playing a gamba game. Let's go. Oh wait. No not yet
We need to buy and use. Okay, Uranus use
Okay, and then we'll use him reroll
Um, nope. You cannot tempt me fellow beast. Uh, don't be afraid to get I just got rid of you buddy
Okay, please be rare and good a freaking a sake uncommon. I have one uncommon
Does he need to be at the back of him?
What's that so there's two uncommon in my deck
Times 4.5 is huge is it? Okay. Okay
It all works out in the end for moment
Right, hmm 7 5 4 2 I'm again. I just want to go for highs
I seem to be doing it in one as well for now ace king queen jack 10 if I'm still doing it in one
So you'll see what you do
Whoa
Okay
Okay, whoa
Wow
Who discard well, I don't need drunkard anymore because no need for drunkard is because I can't skip
No way. Oh come on streamer. Look you cannae tell me
Can skip okay. I need to remember I can skip now because it's gonna mess me up
Oh my god, what was it?
But what happens if you know like what if
What if riefling come on
What if what if
No, you're so stinky
Imagine if it like went the double way add a red seal
Converse all cards in hand to a random single suit
I mean sure add a red seal to one selected card in your hand
I
Red seal let's put it on a king then. I'll keep up
Uh, okay three times multi if a poker is already. Oh, wow. He's actually pretty good as well
But every I am quite happy with everything I've got right now
I mean, I guess the next weakest card we
Have is technically retriggers socks and buskin
But we're not even we're getting 75 000 pair
Red seal the king stick with what you have. Yeah, I shall not shall not be tempted
right
Let's do what we usually do wait. We can jump now
But we can't do it with that
You
Ace king queen right no we can't right there's no point in having that then okay, so ace
King queen jack nine eight. I guess oh, that's so weird
I mean, oh that's mentally very um
Like I can hardly oh, that's perfect
I don't know if poker hand this joker gives a money when a booster pack is skipped. Nah, we're good. Um
I'm gonna grab the voucher. I'm very happy with that
Um, right and then a tarot card. Oh
It's actually a toss up
If I could get a straight upgrade then we can definitely keep up. Oh, that was the wrong choice. I guess
I
That was a wrong choice because we could have got a bit of a
Thing going I'm gonna 25 dollars. Oh, I want to get that though
We'll go for the next right so king jack 10 nine eight seven six five. Oh, that's
That's bizarre
That is bizarre
Oh my gosh
I can't he do that in my head
Uh, right as a stone card. No enhances to the molly cards. Sure. Let's can I use using out? No, I can't well, of course
That wouldn't be fair would it right for the kind to appear through the kind of course again not our freaking problem
Oh
Again, please can we have what I request
uh
High card
Lot are you kidding me? We are having just terrible luck
To get what we want a flush is all the same color
A full house is I mean sure and doesn't make a difference
It doesn't make a difference right next round. Let's go
We're gonna skip because we want the negative joker. What are you play only one hand? Thank goodness
Thank goodness. Okay, so 10. No, right. Let's get rid of the lower
be scaled
Okay, so ace king jack 10 eight
It's be them. It's oh wait. Sorry. Let's also shove you guys into a multi card
So ace king jack 10 eight. Oh god that that's gonna mess it up
Easy peasy lemon squeezy
She's too addicted to gamble. I'm not reading chat. Oh, no second joker from the left needs moving to the right
Second joker from the left
It's moving to the right. Why yes, of course
Um
Strony you should I
Ganba time mommy's getting us out of the box. I think we're winning
I don't want to say it, but
three times motley's the poker
So if we mess up one is straight and it doesn't give us enough we get times three that
Holy moly
Holy moly, that's insane
Okay, please for the love of everything just give me
Are you
Oh wait, there is Saturn Saturn there is
The second straight gets hella strong. You literally and unstoppable right. We'll do that. Why not card extra card in shop
The obelisk. I don't like the obelisk any obelisk fans
Hierophant bonus cards left to right
Okay five
Can become a queen
How many queens do I have? No, I have five queens. Okay
I have five sevens. What the heck have I got seven in this deck? No, okay a five can become
a
Jack
No, we can jump so ace jacks. We actually a ten would really be more beneficial
Sealed king double the sealed king got it got it got it
Let's go double the kings
Right, and then we don't have enough through doing anything again. There's no
Wow, okay ace king
Oh, well wait, what why does my hand seem so small?
So what I need a nine
I don't want to throw away. I mean we only need to do it once so I guess we can throw it away
It's not the nicest thing to throw away like all of this, but
We could in theory
Do that
I just need a ten or a nine to be honest. Okay, there we go. Bing bing bing bing bing
Even though I've got the jump
Okay, how much are we getting pair of round played 187. Okay. I think this is a win and round. Sorry
Well, I think this is a win and round. What's the deal here pair? No, no, no
tarot card
The world a gold card
Sure, why not? Oh wait. No, let's make you a gold card
uh and then
I can just straight up skip this devil the three
I can add a ten which will help me do my skip a bit more like
Ace queen ten
And then yeah, I kind of have the ten lets me access lower skips and then just skip all this
Maybe
Well, this card stays in hand. I mean, no, it seems a shame
I mean, I can do the skip I can do the the street skip thing. It's fine. It's fine
Okay, can queen ten eight six
It's so good though like it's so good hydration check
Oh my god
Thousand
Saw is but with one. Oh, we've sold one
Uh, of course it's playing cards. It's not tarot cards because that would be too kind of the game
The eight already popping off literally shows up instantly
The three would have been better gotta hold the gold and steel can't play them for that thing
Oh, I thought oh hold the gold. I thought it was to play the gold one
She is playing the best base deck. Don't jinx the streamer man. No, no, no, we're doing fine
We're doing fine with the I can roll a tarot. No
One and four chance to upgrade poker hands. No
There's nothing that we can really get tempted by
Be at this stage unless it's a negative is the only thing I'm willing to skip for like we're doing good
I want tarot cards. I don't want to be adding
I mean, I guess maybe I can add more high stuff if it's got a high card in it. Okay. Yeah
10 multiplier
Is it high high give me a high number
Nine is much better. Oh, there's an ace though
Okay
Okay, let's go next let's go nice all spade cards are debuffed. Yeah, that's not really a problem. My ace king queen jack ten night
done
done in one
Off done in one are you jokin?
Is it what is anyone even sweating the heck is a tablet of stone? Honestly? I've never used it yet. Okay. Let's use the wheel of fortune
Oh
Retriggers all face cards. Okay
Re-rolls cost a little bit less. I'll take that
I appreciate that kind gesture
Please can I have the planet not the other one? Yes saturn? Yes, please. Thank you. What does it look like for saturn?
um
180 by 19
Whoa, that's great
We're getting pretty expensive out here. We are
Hashtag winning again. We'll just pick a high card if we've got it. Yep
Get get on in
Uh
We could re-roll for cheap. Why you are different
Nope re-roll for cheap. Well, it was a high card
Now watch us for it re-roll for tires. Yeah
Yeah
By news and that got 15. I'm gonna use it now
Wow
Okay, let's
Keep her money in case something real good comes up
Mega arena mega buffet. No the only thing I care for is a lovely jubilee a lovely jubilee
um
Negative joker so you cannot tempt me game. Okay ace. Can't oh, no, that's a big leap
Nine oh, it doesn't go either way
Well, I might need that hold on
Okay, yeah, so what do you do creates a planet card if it's still held in my hand
Okay, well that one's gonna create a planet card
Ace king queen jack 10
main
draft
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no. Sorry. I'm only that's fine. It's fine. I'm still gonna get a planet card. It's fine
It's fine. I'm still gonna get a planet card. Yeah. Yeah, that's how it works, right? Smile
It's fine. It's not a big deal. What?
For it. Oh, we got a sign. Thank you
Thank you. Love you game. Love streamer. Love me streamer luck. Love me game shiplash
Uh, all right, come on Saturn
Close enough. I'll take it
It's not close enough for whatever
Still gets you another Saturn another turret card
So what do you do multi card bonus cards?
Oh
Oh my god, wait shortcut now it gives us 1.5. Holy moly
Short cut gives us 1.5. This is getting outrageous. Sorry. This is getting outrageous this run
Oh my god
Right, we'll buy these both and use them against my greater judgment
Save our money in case there's something good streamer luck is giving that dope mean literally I feel so much better
After yesterday's stream
Right, let's turn some stuff into space. Why not? Let's turn a spade into a spade. You know what I'm saying?
And then a glass card of
I don't like the idea of breaking anything. So I'm putting on a low. I know streamer bad, but I know
Okay, so
Kind of want to leave you in
10 9 8 7
Yeah, we do not have much going for us
Okay, so get rid of you
We want to keep oh my god, this isn't easy
I don't I know that silly ace king queen jack 10
I know that'll create a pot a planet, but
I mean we can kind of waste a little bit
Okay, hold on right ace king queens get
To 10 to 8
And we get a planet. Okay. That actually worked in our favor somehow streamer luck. Well, I know
I just got here and this stuff is always create literally absolutely crazy right now
So for those of you who are kindly joining us
Um, we have retrigger all
Face cards, which means the higher cards and our deck has got like 5 5 6 5 and for the face cards
We have a negative
Which is a cheeky spectral if I destroy the six which I've not been using at all. Um
Got the fortune teller so every time I use a turret, but then we have the shortcut on streets
We have the baseball for on commons, which we have two on common
a third on common
Then a multiplier if we do a straight and then a multiplier if the hand's already been done before so it's getting out of hand
But in a good way
You could just skip the jack and done ace queen 10 8 so
Again, we got Saturn. So we're gonna just straight up level up. I have absolutely no problems. Uh, maybe Saturn again
It was close
It was between one or the other but it's fine. It's fine. And then again, we're gonna add a high card in
Um
I think 10 is just an assured way to win at this point
reroll
devil, yep
Come the Joker gains a mall. I mean, I'm not gonna buy it pair
Conceived hand played without scoring the high cards interesting
So you want to oh absolutely
Absolutely
Played face cards have a chance to give mere money right what way up against hold on blind
Nope
and nope
The fish cards drawn face down
Something tells me we're gonna be okay against the fish. Okay. I don't know. I just have
Uh, three bucks of the heart the card is held. Okay. So what jack 10 98 7
Okay, so we'll just shove the five devil
one two
three four and five
Yeah, something tells me we're not going to be struggling through this gameplay
2.5 is still your highest combo though
Yeah, I was a little lipped with it
We get so much money as well
Two bucks for four hands remaining two bucks for four discards at four bucks. Sorry money and stuff one consumable slot and you come
and you come
um
Sure
Free money. Thank you and we get a little level up on that
Again with the playing cards. It really does not want to give me tarot cards. Does it?
Give me the king give me has
We'll just pick the
That's fine. We're just literally we're gonna max out on high
What do you do earn four dollars if the poker hand has a straight?
Yeah, you can you get negative poker cards in the shop or is the rarity of it insane because I don't think I've ever
done it
Rerolls the blind forces one card to always be selected
I mean
With our skip is that really that bad?
All right, I'll buy you so we can use you four of the canes
Free money
It won't always be a straight
Chances non zero. There's a voucher. You can get random negatives, but it's so rare
I'd be oh wait, I can't okay use please. Thank you
Yeah
Uh sure by that and we'll use that
Uh the point in rerolling at the moment because our hand is full and we need access to our deck
Oh, yes
Okay, so strength maker to
Uh 10 I guess
We've got seven coins
An ace. Oh, you know what make it an ace. Why not boom boom boom boom
What
Wait
What did I
Huh, what did I just do?
That was oh
Okay, it's not a big deal. It's not a big deal. It's not a big deal. It's fine seven six five three two
brav
Brav I wasn't reading strength. We'll just lost an ace. I'm sorry
I got confuzzled. Okay. I thought it was the thing
Like the oh
Yes for how many steel interesting. I don't have I don't have it, but it's fine
Oh, we just need a few more saturns to make up for that. That was my bad. That was my it's fine. She's winning too hard
I don't need to think exactly. I don't need to think we're just
Steam rolling up. I guess I mean, I guess
Though I really want a six. Oh, there's only two
Do I really want
No, I don't I'm oh wait. I could have used that gray card. Oh
Well, I did it now. All right, let's see if we can get a cheeky negative because why not
One discard each round. Come on. Give us a negative. You know, you want to re-rolls boss blind and initial card
Nah, give us a
Yeah thingy or give us a tarot
Jeez
Are you serious?
Got the shop hates me
Oh, okay, there we go
One more
Increases rank of the two so like oh for goodness sake. Yes, and you come
Silly, okay increases rank
Repeat after me increases
rank
So what the five and the three to push them up the board
Increases rank you
Silly sausage you
Such a silly sausage, right
Uh jar, uh nine
Nine eight seven six four. Yeah easy piece of lemon squeezes
We can't stop you can't you can't do it. I'm on fire
Sixteen dollar reduced don't mind if I'd urinous
Urinous what are you doing here? Please I call upon saturday. Yeah
Uh
Then sure let's call upon okay, there's not any other variation that we really want so fine
It's fine and then two tarot cards, which will absolutely take um
I know I shouldn't but I can't help it. I love the gambas. No
Okay, and then no glass card multi-card
Bonus cards increase the rank maybe
Uh
We'll do molly cards. Why not? Let's make that jack and ace worth some
worth simsing
The true halo. Oh my god. Is that halo? Is that master chief from the hit game?
A fortnight. I'm sorry
That why you're so cool looking. Oh, that's messing up my eyes
Thank you very much for coming to member. I appreciate the
direct support
Retriggers all cards. No
Yeah, let's go
Right, why are you forcing me to play a king a queen a jack a ten?
No, that's up here. Shout out to all my players right so
Back and still throw away for
I know it. I know it seems crazy
Wait
That changes every hand
That's so dangerous
Oh because it's selected it would get thrown away dafty
Oh, we won on the deck. We did it first freaking try good thing. I didn't bet against you damn straight
Little thing you
I am so dumb. Of course. It would throw away the selected card. I was like, I'm going to play around this
We are very lucky. We actually
Did that whole ole money. All right. I'm not going to do endless modes
Have at least two polychrome jokers
Two plus multi for every five dollars you have
Okay, curious little hydration check start run with no face cards and you're
No face cards
Right, we've got a seal for red blue yellow green. We don't
One plus joker slot, but one less hand
Hmm one less hand so three hands total
Hmm curious
I've already forgotten what one less hand but one more joker slot. Okay. Well, we've got six five
We've got dupla vase
I mean we'll play the doubles two pair. Why not? Well, that really wasn't that much points if I'm going to be honest
Uh, I thought that was going to be a little bit more
Uh, we do have a suit in the distance
I might regret this but
Okay, we got the suit
We got the flush. Yeah
Okay, there we go. We made it. We made it. It's fine. It's fine. Right. We're back to normal economy. So
Not the game already pushing us to try and
Um do two pairs. No, we don't have anything that shapes the deck. Yeah
Our economy's rubbish, are we gonna win the
If I fail the hook discard two random cards each time please
I actually think we need to invest, you know that
Wait the hiker. Yeah, okay, okay
Uh, sure and we'll level up two pair because I'm a little bit nervous about this last one
Oh wait
I didn't realize we were or we weren't at the boss fight yet. Hold on. I shouldn't have done that but we did it anyway, so
Let's do ranks. We already have two doubles and we did just level up pairs. So shout out to all my pairs
We're gonna throw away that five so it's no longer in our inventory
Um, and then we are going to repeat and do the exact same thing
Two doubles throw away the five and there
We almost had it. Sorry my impression was again two doubles
And so just throw away one
Uh
There we go
I wouldn't say easy that was our last hand
A bit of a rough start I have to admit
I mean we can use a tarot
Or we could do three of a kind. Um
Early hiker is pretty good
We don't have anything that shapes us
I kind of want to get economy going. Fuck it. We need we need a gamble. We need gamble. I need economy
discard two random cards pair hand played well
Well, let's do that and see oh, of course the ace goes flying into space. Um
We're getting incredibly lucky with the
The cards though. I think if you go for flushes straight house, you'll win this boss fight. Hmm. Okay. We'll one it thankfully but
I need to retrain my brain because it wants to oh my god
Did you hear my stomach?
That's not gonna be enough is it no it doesn't look like that
I mean it would be kind of oh no, we only have one hand left whole holy moley. I was about to throw there
Um
Okay, get rid of these
Okay, that's fine. That's fine. We're safe. We're safe. Relax
No flake. It's called being bad at about true
Okay, that's fine. We didn't get any interest but we will next round
so
That's just awful by all the kids. Oh, did we do it?
We could shape our deck right now. What's the what the beans can I get a base?
Next base addition Joker is free and a foil
Hmm
Minus one hand size. Hmm. I do not have much faith for this
I think we're gonna have to shape the deck right now
Earn five bucks for each discarded ace
A first discard of round has only one card
Oh for goodness sake
That's not shaping the deck at all
for you
First played face cards give times to it
Please don't help me
Earn an extra dollar of interest for every five bucks you have at the end of the round
Right, I don't think we're gonna win and for that reason alone. I'm going to discover that card
I know it's going to be frustrating being like you're literally thrown because you're not
I think we're already to pass the point of winning
We'll do a free Joker in the next shop, but
I for each earned five bucks for discarding an ace
Five four three two nothing
The black deck is the hardest to play. Yeah, and I'm needing something to
Yeah
I
Right what I need a 10 under queen
Close but no cigar a 10
Okay
Okay, well
Well
That's why I bought that because I didn't think we'd be lucky and yeah, no no got it
Literally what can I do a true purple that's a three of a kind
Can't do nothing else, right? Okay. Let's try that again. Let's try that again. We unfortunately didn't get anything that was kind of complimentary
So again one post joker slot, but minus a tiki hand
That was rough right. What are you uncommon Joker?
I
Skip that for the rare because you can't do two in a row for some reason
Let's go for double vase
Shoot easy easy to win off the bat for these ones. Um
10 98
Gonna work um
Gee imagine if you gave me
Oh, wait, you know what? Let's just play the doubles and get rid of that
God this this game does not like me
Wait, okay, we'll just do a full house. That's fine. That's fine. It's fine. We can do a full house. See it's fine relax
Okay, what are we looking at? What are we looking at?
And
Well, we can't buy anything
I think we're gonna have to just go in
And try and do something like that could be better. I'm gonna be honest that could be better
I think we'll invest in
Oh
Why are these so sucky and not the good kind?
Okay, we're gonna skip the rare
Sorry, we're gonna skip the blind in order to do get a free Joker because we need jokers to instantly
Shoot maybe
We need jokers to help us out played cards with spades to give plus three wins scored spade
I don't even have one spade on hand. So that's not happening
Unless I'm just throwing everything in the bin
I mean, I could sorry the smart stomach internally farting if I came up in my um, I could go for a flush on
heart
This is my first stream. Wow. Hello. Thank you for the tip. I appreciate it
Your first stream and it's me being rubbish on freaking Baltral shaking my head my head
Or did you come in right at the start where I showed the pregnancy artwork? Hmm. Hmm
Be honest. So when was it?
I don't know what to do
I could go for a flush with hearts
Okay, that actually kind of worked out somehow
And that got me 200 for that play which is all I need
This is
Not good not not good at all. I think I might have to discard for a flush of spades
Oh
My god
I think we're better going for diamonds. Oh, no, they've only got six diamonds
So the odds of pulling us. Okay. Sorry. I'm so sorry. This is gonna look painful, but
Yeah, okay, that's what I wanted
Okay
That paid off somehow that paid off and we get a free joker out of the shop. What is it?
I'm
I don't have anything
Oh, this is cursed
This is cursed so much
I
Have nothing shaping this again
Add one voucher three hand size base chips and mullies or have
Brothers is too hard
And not the good game
I have nothing
Oh
There's no point in spending any money I have no direction
I have no direction in my game
There's
Oh, I don't I don't believe maybe we'll try a different pack next round
Because uh, I do not think we've got this
What's this ace ken queen jack right so give me a ten
So go
Give me a ten
You know your funny game, I don't like you
I don't think we've won this I think we'll try a different deck because holy moly is this deck freaking hard like not the good kind
Why we we might just have to fucking put everything into space honestly
Doubles I mean
Should we just
Right I've never used this before the credit card, but
I think we're just gonna have to go all in or else like we just straight up can't win
To convert the left death select two cards converts the left into the right. So this is the one we do want
So take the two make it a queen
Oh, but then there's what I don't even want to use the wheel of fortune ain't gonna get scone for me
We're just gonna go in today. I'm sorry
Hi, thank you for joining
um
Hearts not
The only thing is spades. We're even interested in multi cards. Yeah, we're just use mullies on the highs
This is rough
We can go into debt but over a card slot. I don't think so
I don't think so base chips
I don't know if I'm making any of the right decisions, but this is like this is terrible
Oh
Absolutely terrible. No, what are you uncommon? Okay, so that's good
987 no, we can't do nothing there. All right, let's get rid of the wee ones
I know we need a 10 and and obviously it's not gonna give me one
We got a McMansion only to lose it in the next round literally that game was so good clubs flush. Oh
Okay, you are absolutely correct. How did you even see that?
Play
Oh wait, is this spades? Oh, it's spades. Oops. It's the other one I need
Are you kidding me
This
Game is such a troll one minute. It's like, yeah, don't worry. I got you
I'll get you addicted real quick baby cakes and then the next minute. It's like now you're on your own
The whip flash I get from playing this game
Okay, that this guy is saving us right now
I
Would absolutely adore an extra hand size. Thank you
Okay, a minus four. That's fine
One discard each round two plus hand size
But an uh hand size down
I need something anything to shape this run
No
Spades and clubs are confusing. I'm too small brain honestly get the plus two joker
Like
Like I might as well just go all out
I'm gonna pop. Why is this game so hard this game would I'm just I'm going full debt
Mummies losing the house mum mummies failing her mortgage payments. That's it. I owe so much ASMR right now
Wa wa wa diamonds hearts clubs spades wait, what what we're picking
Two times multi two and four chance to get destroyed though
I feel like you're just gonna get destroyed instantly 50 chance of it popping away
Card can be used in any suit. I feel like maybe just I feel like we have to go spades. I know it sounds silly, but
I don't want to be homeless. I mean, are you technically homeless if you can
That's it. Are you technically
Oh
Next base edition shop joker is a free and holographic. Well, we're gonna have to go for it
Not that one though
Um
You can't be homeless if you can technically
Get inside somewhere and have a home there wink wink right discard all that
Okay, I gave me a space
This is the this I think we're gonna have to go suits
A flush sorry my pardon me. I think we're gonna have to go with flush
What are you you're free for each joker card? Absolutely. What take out take away a discard I guess
Yeah, and then in you come
And then
Yep, I will go into debt for spades because we want all the spades
And then I can't go into any further debt. That's fine
Okay
Spades or play only
Oh, well, it's over now in that suits spades and then
Do the rank and then turn all you guys into spades
Okay, and then do a suit again and then ace did it since we can only play one round. Good luck
Okay, well we have her we have our bearings
Which is we want things to be a
Flush
And do we upgrade flush via celestial hat flush flush flush flush flush dripper
We are in so much debt
Choose two four jokers
Would it all spade cut?
Yeah
Are you serious?
All spade cards are debuff. Meanwhile, this is the only thing keeping us alive right now
The curse of the credit card
Shawnee owns the debt collectors. Oh gee. Honestly
Now sell the credit card I lose the game if I sell it
Because I'm like in so much debt
That's how they get you this we are literally learning an economy 101 right now
This is how they get you
Should I do the buffoon
You know what wait? No, you're on common, but you're common
So maybe I can pick up an uncommon and then he can come in to play
I'll put you to the end
You know what let's let's get silly with it
Let's get silly with uh, there's only one uncommon
Uh, well this was
Absolutely useless right if I sell you
Then add you
Because you're on common so you're gonna compliment him
Gain chips if the hand contains a straight right. We need a bigger hand size
Oops all sixes doubles all listed probabilities. I don't
Know
We what
Wait, did I kill us with debt?
Oh my god, wait, I don't have my glasses on that that's definitely a minus sign
Uh, my bad. I'm a I'm gonna just sell that
Uh
Yeah, let me let me just sell that my bad. Uh, wasn't who wasn't my intended purpose
Uh, we'll just do the straight then eat
I didn't even know the game worked like that
Well, I think we're gonna have to skip as well because our freaking only card is deep off
How much does one regular flush get us
Wow
We may make it
We may make it in in the end
I
So what happens now?
Okay
The one thing we put right new run we need a different card. That's so hard
That's so hard
Mommy, there's only so much debt a reef Lincoln handle. Literally. Sorry. I completely screwed that run over
Uh, I was getting a bit confused. Okay. I was getting confuzzled. Am I not allowed to be confuzzled?
Rude honestly
Right
Spatial cards may appear in the shop start with a hex
Is that even bad
Destroy all their jokers
Okay
But we don't even
Wait, so if we have two jokers, I'd pull
If we have two jokers 50% one is destroyed 50% the other is
Receives a buff, okay
The run went from mummy please to mother the debt literally absolutely twat that
Uh, just go for double base and we're there
Okay
Can't believe it. I'm actually gonna have to play the economy in this game. Uh
You need but really they go for a bit fun pack and try and shape it off the bat
Against my better judgment adds the number of poker
Times the poker hand has been played this run to the molly
This joker gains
multiplier for each card sold
Resets when the boss is no that's rubbish
Sure come aboard you
And then do that and then it's a 50 50 right, okay, we now have a 1.5
As the number of times the poker hand has been played this run to the multiplier, okay, so we just keep going
I don't think I'm understanding this properly um
We do have a duple of aim
I do we just get rid of all the low
Now the more you play the same hand the stronger it gets
Oh, no
Well, there's another full house. Why not?
So I want to do full house now
Uh tarot another joker
Hopefully we can get a negative joker the next all spade cards are debuff. That's fine. Um
Mummy disassociating in the club playing purely off of vibes. Honestly. I'm getting lost in this loss
Right, that's fine. Clubs are debuffed. That's fine
Right if they're debuffed, I don't even want them in my hand to be honest
I'm sure I'm probably making like some should I just go for a flush
Clearly not
What's this then? I have a duple of e
To appears how much is that gonna get me
No, oh, yeah, that's not even that bad. I don't know how you work, but you're honestly helping. Um
Ten nine eight seven six. I got rid of roots of sixes
Oh wait idiot jack ten nine eight seven
He he he sorry. Sorry. I raised your blood pressure. They're almost hitting send. I'm sorry. I know what did
I almost did it. Okay. We've got one dollar interest. That's what I like to see
Raises the cap on interest
I wouldn't mind that
Initial booster packs are free and I can pick two joe. I might do double skip. You know that
No, I can't
Hmm
What is it booster packs are free initial cards and booster packs? Okay, that might be worth it
Oh, my mouse is uh, please don't die mid game. That would be great. Mr. Mouse
I think we're gonna go and get more money
Uh, we'll do that
I know I should probably invest in two pairs something but
I didn't trust it right. We're gonna get free stuff from the shop and then we're gonna play
Oh
A cheeky double. Is that the best I got?
What does one hand do?
A full house, please work
Okay, that was lucky right what is free in the shop, please help us
Please I beg
Well, it's free. So go for it. Wait bye. Oh, I mean, I guess bye
We does the card or a planet card
So
I don't even oh this run isn't
See when you cannae
When you cannae shape the run right at the start
It becomes like a shot in the dark it really does
I think maybe three of a kind I seem to be or maybe two pairs. They see the most common
Well, you can just you just gotta start picking but that's pressure and stuff
Right must play five cards. That's fine
Uh, right, we just did get doubles. So let's do that play hand
Is that yet? No
Okay, that's not that bad. That's not that bad really. It's we're doing fine for now. We're doing fine
I need to well destroy lower number cards. Yeah
We got nine our economy's getting there
That's pretty good have to admit
These however are the worst why can't I use it?
Do you need to have a second joker to use it the egg
Gains three bucks of sell value at end of round
What it just keeps going up and up and up or is there like a ceiling
Is this like playing the stonks market invest in stonks now and then later it's better
It goes up. Okay. I'll get I've never I've not grabbed it before so I'm glad I can unlock it
It right
Fuck it. No, wait. No, no, wait. No, I should hold on to it
Oh, no, wait, never I should hold on to it because it's a plus 10
Only I would manage that. What do you do spectrum? No, keep your eyes from both of them
But now it does something till you need to sell it
We can get better with the cash later. Honestly, how can I be messing this up so much, right?
Would it create the planet if there if it's held in the hand? That's fine
Oh, wait, I need to delete the smaller cards
I don't know
I just destroy the two
Which wasn't very nice, but I did what I had to do
You discard those okay, we can do a flush again a full house my apologies a full push
Well, there it is
I guess we're going for it with him
With a full house, which I don't normally go for but he will
Uh diamond cards
We might be doing it as if I can even get
Three three times multiplier if you have 16 enhanced card currently nothing
Yeah, no, uh, I'm not gonna be shocked that I I'm not going for that because jase
Plus three multiplier on a diamond how much do you sell for a whole six dollar beautiful stuff, right?
What are we looking at?
Rubbage, right just keep sending it
I think we're gonna have to go full house
Runs if we can even do it because we can't on the first one
And get rid of that play hand
How much?
We're making it by the skin of our teeth for now
For now we can do it
You leveled up again. Oh, he's nine dollars
Ah this nothing is being shaped right now nothing at all
I'm just going for it and our freaking egg is mocking us saying. Oh you want to sell me don't you?
Multi needs to be before
You go here
The daily card get me 2.5 million feels good man
Okay, supernova's at the end. Thank you one day. I'll remember fancy-looking cards to the right
Is to do that day? No, no it is not
um
And then is this the boss by one minus hand size
We're actually doing
Okay in quotation marks. So I I'm confident we at least have this round
Oh, it meant handers and cards in my deck. Uh, we might have to go for a suit
Oh
Thank goodness, thank goodness
Okay
I'd really rather like to keep that to have a hidden upgrade
Uh
But playing this is gonna do like next to nothing
If you draw 10 it's a straight flush
Wait, I have three hands. Hold on. I have two more. Sorry. That's for something again. Right. That's fine
I
Need a 10
I needed a 10 either way right what do two kings do I really want to keep this
Okay, okay
I literally I just I want to level up anything because I'm I'm scrambling right now trying to save this run
Ouija minus hand size. Absolutely not. I'm have I'm perishing
Converts all cards into a straight wait. I'm not doing
No, I need diamonds apparently
Bruh, this this is the worst run. I think we've ever had there's like no point in spending any money
Oh
You believe
I'm perishing
I'm perishing I've got a rank possibly
Okay
Oh my god my stomach's making me feel crazy. Bruh
Honestly, I did it. Streamer luck has to kick in at some point. I think I used it on the first run
This is like awful
Oh
Literally the the egg that is taunting us is keeping us alive. Oh my god. It's ready to help as well
Which I really don't want but hey, I mean we'll get a
A thing so
You know, I'll take you anything that levels up anything. I'll take it
Yep
I
Literally level up anything I am scrambling I'm scrambling
Sure, let's just keep leveling up to a pair
Scramble any harder
Call me eggs because I'm scrambling for anything, right?
Sure, we've got room for another Joker. Let's see if we can shape with four
awful
Oh, I guess you
The egg is keeping us alive. I can't even get rid of the purr guy
Diamonds are helping loyalty card is helping
Poker splash
You had a straight but you tossed it
I don't think I've had enough sleep. I slept all day after stream yesterday and I still don't think I had enough sleep
Airing an extra dollar of interest I wish I could sell
This is gonna come in clutch whenever we're absolutely panicking I don't think I'm gonna have to skip these are rubbish
I
I'm not gonna make it not gonna make it
I do not believe
I do not believe I haven't slept a single segment straight into work after stream. I'll let you zombie
I had enough sleep, but it wasn't enough. Are you me? I am
Um
How do you guys see that so easily?
I'm destroyed from all the crying. I am I'm actually distraught
I
For anyone who didn't see yesterday's stream
I've got John Wick spoilers if you don't want to listen for like the next three minutes
If you just want to close your ear. Oh my god. I can't even open up my bottle of water
Oh, oh, did you hear my wrist crack trying to open this bottle of water? Geez, what did they make the freaking cap out of titanium steel?
Outrageous, um
Did you hear it?
Ew, that's so gross. My wrists are really I have it incredibly. I thought that was the bottle cap
Fine
Um, I have really weak wrists and hands for some reason like all my strength is in my thighs and my
My gluteus maximus. That's where all the strength in my body lies. I have no other strength
I have no strength in my back. I have no strength in my hands my arms my wrists anything like that
Um, it's just all all even my even my toes are stronger because I can grip things with it
Like I have absolutely nothing else going for me
Um
Right jack 10 987
Wait, we only got 1.8. When do you pot? Oh, you don't pot
Oh no
Oh no, right, we've got a full house which is leveled up
We're gonna be okay. I think oh no, we did it. We did it
How much are you $18 or beloved egg is $18 now three of a kind
I don't have anything strong it opens jars with their thighs. Oh, no, you have to tap it on the bunker
um, if you tap the jar lid on the bunker it like
Weakens it and then you can open up
um
Crumbling to dust before our eyes not quite not quite but like literally I can't handle it
Oh, wait, sorry a countertop. It's bunker in scotland
But uh the kitchen countertop is what you call it smile
We call it a bunker. I I know I know
Why why Scottish people? Why do you call it a bunker? I don't know
It's just how it is. It's called a bunker the the kitchen countertop the worktop the whatever the bench the kitchen bench
maybe you call it
I want to pass on by strong his thighs
50 that convention. I'll make all my travels expenses back. I'll have a little sign
50 cents to be stepped on
A dollar to be a thigh crushed until you pass it. That's terrible
I mean, honestly, it would be a way to get your money back, right? I am fully
I have fully accepted this run isn't happening
I'm gonna start beatboxing to cool
Oh my god, you can squeeze the lid with the palm of your hand. I don't have any grip strength either
Could you could you imagine
Imagine no grip strength. You know when people always make fun of folk for having a weak handshake
Imagine the weaker grip
I mean I could I could probably grip it like a vice if I wanted to but my like it hurts
It hurts everything although my gran had absolutely terrible arthritis in her hands
And unfortunately, I'm gonna teach you a fun fact about biology
If you are a chick
Wait, whatever your dad's gran has in ailments, you are almost like 100 likely to get it
However, your mom's gran
ailments aren't necessarily always going to be passed on to you
But if it's your dad's mom or your dad your gran on your dad's side
Then you're very likely to catch those ailments if you're born a chick
That only applies to chick. Is this a scientific fact? Yes, because
Uh, oh my god. Sorry. I love I'm prompted biology lesson. Let's go. Um, so if you didn't know the male
The sperm determines the sex of the child of the fetus
Um, and because of that the male can only pass on a fully
Full so it's x and y chromosome, right?
So the dad passes on an x or a y a y is a hundred percent him an x is a hundred percent his mom
He has no female x inside him if that makes sense. So it's a hundred percent your gran
It sounds really bizarre, but basically I'm like a hundred percent of my I
It's a weird mix. It's really cool though. I absolutely
Absolutely love biology when it comes to that your mom is always an x your mom will always give you an x
So like the reason why men have nipples is to pass down genetic information
For breastfeeding. That's why some men actually end up having like breast tissue
It's completely natural completely normal men are a hundred percent susceptible to breast cancer as well
Please do not think you are immune if you ever find a lump or anything. Do not be embarrassed
I assure you you are not the only man on earth that may ever have a lump in their breast. This is
It is perfectly natural. It is perfectly normal. Do not be embarrassed
I cannot
Emphasize how much any healthcare worker has seen everything at the point at the point you present your symptoms
The healthcare worker has seen everything
Okay
No, your genetic can be really messed up. You can have like disorders and all that
Um
I have tds to potentially have dark
Yes, you need to pass on the genetic mammary gland information because mammals are
Um milk producing so some
Animals take a chicken for example a little chicken gets all its nutrients from the egg
It's all it'll need. It does not need a milk supply. It uses a yolk sac for example to grow
Um, whereas mammals are term
Usually are born a much younger much
Unable to do things especially humans are a fantastic example of mammals being unable to do anything for a very long time
But the reason for that is because the circumference of the head of the baby
Um babies need to be born essentially before full gestation
Because it would um perish the mother so humans evolved to
Give birth around the nine month mark. But actually
Fun factoid the embryo normally is 10 months old by the time it comes out
Yes, the brain still needs to develop a massive example of
Um, the development stage is called ossification
Um children are born with a lot more bones than adults end up with and um
ossification is the process of your
Bones um coming together a fusing together
Which is why babies cannot crawl until usually the six month mark
But uh milestones and children aren't necessarily an indication of good health bad health
Everyone is different. That is why um
A lot of mothers in healthcare are ossification no ossification like oseph something like that
I can't spell the rest of it
But
Yeah, like um
That's why like you might have a story saying like I completely skip the crawl phase
Some children completely skip the crawl phase. They don't even need to do it
Um, they have no desire to do it and then they'll just up and walk
Um after a certain amount of months has formed. It's fantastic. Honestly, it's quite fascinating
Um to think like I'm sure you guys might have funny stories that your mom was all freaked out being like
Ah my poor baby boy wasn't doing this and that and it's like no, it's fine. Don't be silly the only cause for concern
um
Really is a child that cannot latch
It's probably the massive are you joking?
Um
I need a queen now
I was gonna go for a flush
Um
I was a quick talker not a quick walker. Yes, absolutely fun fact skipping the crawl phase is a major sign of dyspraxia
Condition is hard baby. Literally those can't control forelimbs at once. Yes
That's why you had to do tummy time as well to help raise your neck muscles
Because babies pretty much have knee neck muscles to save their the life of them
They like violently swing their head around just like so crazy
Um, oh what am I gonna try and achieve here?
I was gonna go for a flush with hearts, but I only have two discards left
And I've got a bit of a high thing going on here
I was cartwheeling out of the wind feels good man. Honestly come flying out
Well, I actually got four of a kind which is so rare
Sorry, I got so distracted I stopped playing the game. Um
Hmm
Hmm, have I just shot myself in the foot doing such a pit manoeuvre
I think we're gonna have to get rid of them
Yeah, I'm gonna say try and go for doubles like this
Hmm, I don't lose honestly
Uh, this is definitely not oh, of course, he's ready to pop now when I didn't need him
No, these are rubbish. I mean
At least we win but I didn't he need
Oh
Well, I guess pop on the jack then I didn't even realize we were up against that thing
But that's funny. Okay. We did it. We did it somehow. We did it a christmas freaking miracle 11 dollar. He does
Will we go out for two pairs
I think we're gonna shape our deck with two pairs shout out to all my pairs
You're the only thing keeping us alive right now
So does splash not complement two pairs
I don't oh I do not
Does splash not complement two pairs? I don't know. I don't know
We're gonna have to shape it now
We don't have a choice
Splash works for extra two cards
Then what get rid of loyalty card? No, not really splash is good if you have a lot of junk cards
Mmm
All right, we're shape we're gonna have to shape it now or we are basically accept and defeat
So you'll have to forgive me
I'm going to do something very painful and you're not gonna like it
And you're not gonna like it
But we have to do it now or else we have lost lost
We're going for two pairs. So let's go for uranis. Of course. It doesn't show up because why would it
Because why would it show up right now?
Why would it show up?
Why not sell the egg? It's currently giving me a 10 plus at the moment
Um
Until we get
Don't mind if I do
Don't mind if I do you're not gonna like it, but we're going for two pairs shout out to all my pairs
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right my baby don't mess around because
Because it's out for show
Oh, and that joker just came in
These two are gonna come in clutch pretty much
Yep, and I got an uranis, which is exactly what I wanted to see. We're doing it. We're we're going in two pairs two pairs
It just seems to be the matter
What are you mister?
Oh
I'm coming. Oh
Great. Okay
Egg you have done us
Christmas miracles, but your time is up
Your time is up
Your time is up. Oh my god
Right, come on uranis
Yep. Okay. Okay. We shaped it at the most perfect time
How are we looking we want to do highs maybe
Ain't nothing can you teach us more about this female biology?
I was actually gonna do a sex education stream just for the hell of it. Um, because I quite find I find it quite fascinating
Hmm
Sure
Um after play or discard always draw three cards like more
After player discard always draw three cards like three cards only
I know there's a flush there, but we're going for doubles so
We learned so much every stream. Well, I was gonna this sounds absolutely terrible. I was going to get a pair of
Basically model balls and like I was gonna do ASMR like examining your
Um
But obviously with youtube kind of switching things up. I guess that might be a twitter video
Actually, I remember many I need to put that video on twitter. I'm so sorry
I don't know why I keep coming up with cursed ideas, but I can't help it like it's fucking hilarious
I'm like I'm sorry, but imagine like ASMR me with my hands like and I've like got my nails on like oh
Sorry, I forgot to put my gloves on he he no pay no patient contact direct contact. Sorry
And I'll be like oh lovely nice and shaved for me. Thank you
and
That curse it's all good. We're into it. Literally. I'm like I can't stop coming up with like these silly gives me ideas
It just makes me giggle so much
I don't know like it. It just brings me so much joy, right? So we have three
We have three to turn into hearts, which I'm actually gonna oh wait hold on
We actually want more hearts because of this little guy. Oh wait idea. There was another one that has a diamond
That's okay to be dumb. I'm allowed to be dumb. I'm allowed to be dumb
Being dumb is not bad being bad. It doesn't mean I'm dumb. Well, I am dumb, but you know what I mean
All I can think of you going to whip no no like I would be like proper like whispering ASMR like
Just be like thank you for coming to the clinic. You got any concerns? I see
um
You're too late
You're too late the disrespect you have shown me you're too late
Greedy Joker lusty Joker
Clever Joker
Mad Joker clever. I remember I used to always get called the clever girl in primary school
to be like, oh, you're such a clever girl scrawny
Self-right you're complimenting me mr. Teacher. Well, miss teacher
If it's a miss if it's a miss relax relax relax, right?
Relax no play
It's called a humor
Square Joker should I get it?
I don't know. I feel like it's too late for him. Like I've got three plus multiplier when certain car a plus
Not times, but he just gives four check like you're too late, bro
Bro, you're actually too late for bro. Right. We're gonna skip because we're getting a negative Joker
All heart cards are debuff. That's fine
That's absolutely fine with me. Are you kidding me?
You're telling me that I don't have a second double
I
Right, we're just playing doubles. I know that's the buffed and that's the buffed as well
I know I know play the flush
No, I have to go in on doubles everything is stark for doubles now
so I can't
I have to be a good girl and play doubles
We can't be tempted ill of fate
We must be good. Okay
Is there not double have I thrown so many cards away? There's no doubles. Oh, there's oh wait idiot. There's one right there
It's cuz it's blanked out. Okay. It's cuz they're blanked out. I'm dumb
All these curse medically some words are just gonna be in different rooms of the same building
Literally, right. What are you?
That's a shame, but I mean a Joker is a Joker
If it's a flush
Yeah, that's a shame. That's a shame. That's a shame
But we're gonna start redeeming packs. Our economy is good to go honestly. Sure. What's a turret if it's not a carrot?
And oh we can get 20 bucks back a steel card
Steel cards might be your saving grace
I
Dare I say a steel card might be your saving grace
If we can get a few more steel cards, uh, I would not be upset
What we looking at what we looking at creates two copies of one selected card in your hand
Diamond creates two copies of the selected card
Whoa, wait, that's
Three tall
I'm by that anyway
And then let's go again what we're going here next base shop is a polychrome
I'm full
There's no more room at the end. You can only tempt me with negative jokers now
Unless I sacrifice one of these for it
Oh
Oh, I'm sacrificing. I'm sacrificing so hard right now
On top of that the doctor one running between the room is changing outfits honestly
Um, right. I will if I have three aces of diamond, I'll get rid of um the heart joker
Are you just like saws but the game actually is
going against me
Just say you hate me. It's fine. Just say you don't like me. You don't you don't have to spell it out with the cards
Okay, there we go
Greedy and lusty are plus three easy to repair. Yeah, I'm gonna swap out lust
For whatever this hidden guy is what are you?
Play dices
Okay
Right. Goodbye lusty. You've done is pretty good to get here
Oh wait, you won't
I
No point in getting rid of him because I mean he might come in clutch somewhere
You need to go there then you're at 1.5. So you need to go over
And then we hope for urinus. Oh my a bit of urinus don't mind if I do
Uh, and then a full house technically contains a doubly. So I'll take it
I miss tours again, but how's it going? It's going good ish. We won our first move
We had to pivot in the middle of this one
There is a chance
There is a chance, but we're having to
Be very
Mmm
We're having to be on our best behavior
Because this isn't easy
I would like to keep you
We're having we're going it all in on two pairs yet again. It seems to be the best strategy
Just two pairs over and over again
Um
Just because just because
Oh my god urinus fantastic
It's not guaranteed though
It's definitely not guaranteed. What do you do not discovered? I mean we'll discover it because we can
Um
Playing cards, maybe if we can get another one of them
What are you? Whoa
That's op is fuck
Yeah, sorry, I know it's a low number, but that's so op
Hey, we are just gonna go on a bit of a buying. Oh, we got the fill
We're gonna use the fill. I'm sorry. We're gonna use it. It's it's keeping us above the requirements for the round
Hand size next very large blind. I can't swap that out. So we're gonna have to hopefully level up urinus
No one else is sorry, let me check the lens
Net and well, there's no point in that because it doesn't work. Um, low number doesn't matter when you're stacking ballies anywhere. Yeah
Oh when blind is selected gain three, but lose all this. Whoa, that is punishing. Why would anyone want that?
Oh
Okay, an ace gives me a bit extra on top two pair two pair
On a diamond, okay, we're in it. We're in it to win it. I don't know if we have it. It's not guaranteed. Oh, okay
We want to level up urinus. We really do. Sorry, I know I keep calling it urinus
Okay, that's good
We get a level up as well, which is absolutely fantastic
What are you when blind is like to create two no and then a straight no
Urinus again any urin any urinuses? Whoa
Hello, yeah
Big beak close enough, okay
By okay, okay black hole all hands plus one now curious
Curious indeed, right we will spend everything after this
We will spend every penny we can muster
Now we do have a 1.5 in here as well. So we are gonna play and throw with seven
Try and get higher doubles
Yeah, yeah, okay, and then we'll play our aces and our tens and we've done that round
How much does that get okay, we definitely need ace plays
In order to do this big bang right we can sell everything
Urinus any urinuses close enough absolutely. We've got one
Two turret cards, let's see what we're looking at and now give me us we can go all out on urinus
Someone says yeah, right we'll use the urinus so we're gonna use that now that's perfect and then we've got
So like two cards convert the left into the right
Do we want another two?
Selling the left joker make another steal. That's what I'm thinking as well
What are we looking at for the lower numbers other the odds of everything is actually on par other than higher aces and jacks
Turn the four into a steal, okay, and let's just slight two cards convert the left into the right
Okay, we now have two a lot twos
Give him a lot enema enema give him an enema
um
No
Mm-hmm
Creates a copy of a joker destroys a whoa
No
What creates a copy of a random, but destroys all other jokers
No, I think you need to show up a lot earlier than that. Are you couldn't we couldn't even do anything
We're out of money
We didn't even get anything for that
Hmm
Okay, hold on we are gonna take our sweet
our
time
I
Say
I say get rid of these
And keep
No
Get rid of all of these. I know it's a pair
But we need the ace
Anke is good early. Yeah
How's the gambadix go in we might win or lose. I'm not sure
We need the aces okay, that's exactly what we needed. However, we don't have a complimentary pair
So we're gonna do another discard
Okay, okay, we're cooking by gas
Shout out to all my pairs. We're gonna throw away the eight and we're gonna see what this ace does
Um
Okay
I'm not
Mmm
Oh aces in snowberries we're gambling don't look don't
Hi snowberries. Hi, I say thank you for redirecting into me. I appreciate you kindly
Um, hello snowberries. We're gambling today because yesterday I was emotionally distraught after finishing john wick
Do not finish don't watch john wick if you're not emotionally stable. That's all I'm gonna say all I thought
John wick was about pew pew. Ha ha cool guy. Uh, no, don't do that
Bye hi readers. Thank you for joining in. How was aces streamed? Did you enjoy it?
If I can pull a steel card
We might be out the gutter
We are currently on the very last round of a run on a deck that we haven't done a one a win on
It's a very large bind at 300
We will win or we will riot is sevens here better instead of tens because of the diamonds
I don't know
A stream was a cluster
What did she do was it it was an ASMR that stream the ac was streaming was it?
greedy joker
Is it better with a diamond played cards with diamond give plus three
We could hold off and use that then
Oh, you're playing oh, that's right. You were playing guild wars because her
Her streaming equipment had to be on the lowest setting bless her cotton socks. I yes, I recall now. I recall
And I didn't shoot yeah, okay, I recall yeah her she had to put it on the lowest graphics. I recall I recall
Also, we gave her a wedding dress and a ring. Oh, and you ran a train on her excuse me
I beg your finest pardon. You did what in to my icy
You ran a train on my daughter
Excuse me
You you dressed her up like a Barbie doll in a wedding dress and gave her a ring
And then you ran a train on my daughter
And you didn't invite me into the culture. Excuse me
There was a dog pile at some point you ran a train on ac
We're at her official daddas now. I'll have you know, okay
daddas, okay
You guys have so many nicknames snowberries daddas ojisans
I like ojisans because of my accent. I'm like, oh
Come in a side ojisans like my accent makes this a stronger
The culture spot was taken rude
That's my chair. I'll have you know
What was that about chair?
Right, we're doing it. We're doing it
We've got an ace. We've got a diamond to activate on both these the eight will not count
And we've got one hand remaining so we need to
Come on, baby. Come on, baby. Oh, what does it mean?
I have the odds to pull one more ace
I have to go for the ace
Oh my god, this is so close. This is come on game. Give me the ace streamer luck. Oh
Okay, okay. We have pulled the ace. I repeat we have pulled the ace
We might as well discard the lore in case of a diamond pool of 10
In case of a diamond pool on 10
Yes
I might as well get rid of the jack and I might as well get rid of the king and pull for diamond 10
Yep. Yep. This is the best way to do it and maybe a steal
Unlucky well we can submit our jacks then
They didn't pull the two such a shame they didn't pull the two
I
Want to use the tens for scholar scholar scholar played aces give
This is it. This is the best we can do
I
Throw the two out there. Why not? I'm just giving them a little two
We don't even have anything like that. I just give them a two as a tip. Okay
Okay, well
Let's see
Do we do it
Do we do it? Oh
Hey
No
Oh
We say a ball here in scots like oh if it's really close you go. Oh, that was a ball here
right
One more run and then I'm going to redirect into she be because
This is a shorter stream because I am uploading the girls as highlights from debut
I'm just going to check if the she be streaming cotton bum
A bit of she be cotton bum. Yeah, she might be live. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Is she having a break today? Yeah
Oh my gosh. She's having a break. How did I can't believe it?
I can't believe the girls that be allure are making sure they're healthy and okay, uh
Uh on emmy's off emmy's off as well. Okay. Um
Uh, uh, okay. Okay. Hold on
So it's mersey on or am I the last one up? I'm the last one off
Oh, no
Oh, no, this can't be
I was a mersey's having a day off too. Right. Hold on. Hold the phone
Hold the phone we can do something about this hear me out
I
Could in theory
go away for
five
It's not gonna work. It's not gonna work. Vila is gone
Vila is gone. We can't do it. Right. Hold on. Let's play one more deck
Uh
Wow, okay. Let's play one more deck and then we'll redirect into the
A yumi plus girl because there'd be nothing but kind and lovely to us
Uh, what about ac ac redirected into me vila has fallen literally everyone like oh, how can I possibly keep up with vila streams?
Well, you can now
She
Okay, I will make a deal we'll play one more round
I'm gonna very quickly make a cup of tea and go for a pee we'll play one more round
We'll redirect into a yumi plus girl once I go offline
You will start to notice that the highlights of the girl's debuts go up again
I will do it in order of who debuted first. So it goes ac and azura then
Mercy then emmy then she be then me last. Okay
So they're all gonna pop up roughly at the same time
Like uh, maybe 15 minutes apart because it takes a while to fucking do all the descriptions
But please do look out for that
Do I want a cup of tea?
I don't know. I'm a feeling a cup of tea
Or do I just want to go again?
The plane has hit vila headquarters
And the funny thing is we actually do have a headquarters, which is the most funniest
We we considered accepting mail at the headquarters location on behalf of the girls, but it's not possible
Um
We thought about it because we were we discussed having po boxes
But um, unfortunately with the rise of air tags and trackers we cannot accept mail at anyone
I said to the girls I was like not then you open up po boxes. I understand if you're interested
At first I was gonna test it out myself. Um
Because I can get packages sent to the headquarters. I know that sounds fucking ridiculous, but there is like, I know
Yeah, believe it or not. Um
But then I was like
I would have to open up all the packages
At the headquarters location to make sure there's no air tags or anything
Um, or any biohazard stuff
And then it was like I was gonna have to rent out a freaking conference room
And then I was gonna have to go through all the packages and then it kind of defeats the
This surprise because like opening stuff up on stream is like quite funny
You want an officer? I mean
I mean
I can give you a boardroom meeting tour if you want man
Like the actual boardrooms
How am I supposed to poison the staff? Why would you want to poison the staff? What the fuck?
I'm part of the staff the fuck
Better keep it safe virtual headquarters. Nope physical location headquarters
Actual physical location headquarters. I know cringe
How did she do it ladies and gentlemen mods just that man's balls mods get that man. Don't leave us moment
Wait, so no cup of tea or cup of tea
Um, you'd also have to check the inside of the item for an air tag. Yeah, like the
It just gets so dangerous
Unless I was to record the video at the headquarters
And then take back what I desired
A new was safe home and I would have to buy like a tracker as well
But tracker devices don't always work
tracker detector
Wouldn't you get a higher sniff dog? No, I don't think can dogs sense like motherboards and stuff
And
Yeah, I know it's a shame because I would absolutely enjoy being streamers do like those like accepting your packages type things
And like someone like sprays fart spray or something on it
Although I think one of the sadder ones I caught was like someone sent someone ladybugs
But they all died and I was like that is actually really sad. It's not much of a prank is it if
We little things perish for it
But you could also just amp the box. Oh, let me just oh, sorry
I forgot to mention have amp grenades just sitting next to my seed collection. Yeah
Um
Don't send live animals or insects in the milk. Yeah, it was like
I can't remember if it made like headlines or whatever
But someone purchased like 10 000 ladybugs and sent it. But obviously, you know, there is no
um
There was no
Like refrigeration to put them to sleep in the travel
It was like in the heat in the boxes getting thrown about and when they arrive
Obviously, they all had perished and I seem to remember that story in particular because I'm so sad
It feels weird man. As long as there's no iphone within 100 meters. Don't air tags not work. Just open them up and
I have no idea
Sadly doggos can't sniff out an rtx 490
Kind of better that they died. They could be invasive. Uh ladybugs are invasive
Little ladybug little ladybird. We we actually say ladybird in the uk
Little ladybird
Wouldn't a microwave do this? You want me to microwave everything that comes through in the packages? Just shove it in there
No, that's fine. It's fine. Just shove in
It depends on the breed
Harley Quinn ladybugs. Okay
I'm gonna name that right
Start the run with no face cards in your deck. Let's see how bad this is and it's called abandoned deck
We do have an uncommon joker for free. So I might be interested in that. What are you after gain 25 economies?
That is more money than we'll make doing that. Right. Fuck it. We're going all in boys. We're going all in
Wait, so we still get aces. We just don't get okay. Okay. So get aces
Uh, let's throw you guys away
Wow, that did nothing. Please don't ever do that again
Okay, we've got a full house. Let's go
I'm gonna send myself to valer hq. Oh, do you remember that prank?
Um, we're like these people claim they ship themselves and then an airline had to come out and be like, don't be so effing ridiculous
Of course these people didn't ship themselves through a fucking box or something because they like it was like a prank youtube channel
And they were oh, yeah, we totally shipped ourselves
And it was like don't be so ridiculous like the airline had to get involved in publicly like denounce them
For being so silly. Wow. Okay. Yes. That was that was definitely worth it. Right. You're free
Sell this card to create a free double tag. What does that even mean?
This joker gains when a booster pack is skipped
Interesting if your airship a living creature is cargo what you get at the other end of the corpse basically
Face cards hardy hardy hard adds double the rank of the lowest card. I mean that's better than nothing
If I skip a booster pack, I mean, I might as well go down there
Not really fuss for consumable slow at this point in time
What are we up against? Oh, we've got a negative
All heart cards are too fast
Well
Next round I guess
All right, we're gonna go for the negative. We're gonna select a booster pack a booster pack any booster pack lovers
We'll go for a pair and throw away the four of you
Open tarot and skip it. Oh wait, if you open the the pack and then skip it it adds to it
I thought it meant skip it entirely. Okay, that makes
slightly more sense
Than the way I envisioned it in my head. I'm here. I'm here. I do apologize for that one. Okay. I understand then
This is the first time I've had this guy involved. So we're getting there
Right air in five bucks if three or more face cards
I might as well buy it and sell it I guess
What a joke I skipped for that
Right, so if I buy and then skip it, which is fine. I'm happy to skip that. That's not really a big deal
and skip
Oh
Whoa, okay
Bye
What do you do plan out?
That's actually pretty good. Hold on a minute
Oh, you need to face your problems. I can't believe it. I have no face cards
That's honestly pretty good though
But if I skip
Yeah
I'm going to do the tarot card one because it naturally gives us the goods. I don't really need a consumable swap. So, you know
already have
Nine eight seven six five four three two. Of course. I don't have what I need
Give me a seven or something. Whoa
Uh, you never normally do that for me. So thanks buddy
Ten nine eight seven six, so
You ever do these two?
Sugar I only have one more discard left
So what I need a seven
Are the odds of a seven? Oh seven's pretty high. Fuck it. You know what you know what you cheeky fuck
You cheeky
You cheeky cheeky right, but we've got three more hands. So it's fine. But I need a seven or five or something
Oh
This game has jokes
Nothing but jokes clearly why did I get four there?
What did you I don't know
I mean, I guess
I wasn't even paying attention. Okay
If first hand of round has only one card add a permanent copy to deck and
to deck
and you come
And then again if we
Yeah, if first hand of round
Has only one card plate add a permanent copy of that card to the deck and draw it to the hand
Okay
Right, we're gonna skip these to get a little busty-wusty
unless
Should we go out all out on aces?
Fuck it. If it's got an ace, I'm taking it. If it's got an ace, I'm taking it
Uh, we're gonna skip that and then we're gonna add to a little multiplier here
What are you?
Planet card uncommon joker for free first hand is drawn face down
right
He's twitching. He's ready
Yeah, we're going all out on aces. Fuck it
She we've got five aces now
The unit works well for four of the kinds of clone 800 aces literally and that's the plan
10 9 8 7
Of course, that was too good to be true. Let's do double b's and five why not?
Surely this is the correct move
Oh, we did it. Oh, wow. Okay. That was good. That was good. Um
Sell the card to disable the current no
So what am I going for? I don't know. I don't really know what I'm going for
Just skip
I don't really have anything shaping what we want to do at the moment
Um
Never seen this game before. What's the goal? It's like a
Someone says it's a rogue like but with poker mechanics. Yes
Um, there's a lot of different aspects to the game. It's gonna look absolutely chaotic right now. Um,
But it's quite an easy and tampering since free money
You make money forever
Oh
Yes, basically
I don't know if it's better to skip to keep getting this up. I feel like that's gonna add up over time like really big
I'm sure I'm gonna regret it, but
Oh wait, I could have got more money to buy more packs. You know what?
I might not be the smartest, but I'm here for a good time again
We're gonna have to skip because we don't even have anything that
is
Shaping our deck other than this really doubles the lowest
I don't even know what that means and we're gonna try and get more aces. What's going on here?
Did we go for a free joker?
Fuck it
Oh, this is terrible
Now the odds of us pilling an ace are high so what if we just no don't sell it you give her play
Okay
Okay, okay, okay
Then we just throw it away
Which is a shame to do
Now I'm noticing this one isn't budging anywhere which makes me think it's an ace
I'm gonna regret this but hey, oh right. We've got a duple V and we'll get rid of the three
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. I mean we're kind of looking at two pair again, especially with the amount of aces we're getting
And we're about to get a Saturn no urenus close enough
Close enough close enough right urenus will level up her two pair rewards
I can't get away from two pairs. I honestly can't eat
Okay
Not the best
Because we actually want to keep skipping packs that we open
One, you know, we'll just buy everything
Multi-card steel card joker must have room. Well, I just lost room so
You could have tried for a four of a kind on the aces
Yes, we're going to work towards that
Right, we're gonna buy these and skip them
a sigil and
Yeah, again, not really a Ouija just sounds like a terrible idea. Converse all cards in hand to a single random suit
No, we're not doing flushes. We're doing double base. We're gonna skip. We've got now plus 15 on this bad boy
Again, we're gonna open up a joker
No
We're gonna skip again. We've just never plus 18. We're absolutely
Having a good time with him. We're gonna see if we're gonna duplicate
Would we give what would we give up sell this card to create a free double tag? What does that even mean?
What is a double tag gives a copy of the next selected tag
So
That what
Next time you skip the effect happens twice
Huh all right you're twitching
You
Steel steel ace
Beautiful oh that actually played for you a bit of money there a steel card steal the two
And then we've got two multipliers on the deck
And then do what up here
Not the two put it on the sick
Um
I don't know what to try and roll for maybe another ace
Keep the four try and roll for an ace. Okay. There you go. There you go. Exactly what we wanted
Uh, throw me the two. Um, we've got two. Yeah, hold on. We're gonna end up with you
Hey
How much work was the cola putting in?
That wasn't that really wasn't that good
So
Hey, I'm gonna lose
The cola did nothing
Oh, but I'm gonna get two holographics if I win though easy win on what show me what four ever came
There's two more aces to pull
Could do five of a kind
What should I just try and pull for another ace?
Five of a kind should be more than enough bloody. Oh, so
Oh, there you go. I still could technically get another one. Fuck it. Ah, I could do imagine though
So what I want to do these four and then have the 1.5 and 1.5
I'm okay. We're saying goodbye to the planet. It's not the biggest deal five aces
Oh, that's way stronger. Holy crap. Yeah, that's way stronger
All right
God that was not a rolling smoke though. These two negative jokers we're gonna get they better be good. It not negative
Are you joking me?
Right that's free
So we're gonna get it and then sell it because it's fucking rubbish
And then we're gonna get the probability one. I know that gives me fat like but it's gonna expire
I'd rather pick this up than something that expires
You know
Like at least this is perma
So anytime small player you need to go the back
But you won't plan it any planet card that's used. I might just start buying
Anyway, I start buying
Right, we're just gonna start using cards to get this times up. I know I shouldn't and I should skip but
Fuck we're just ruining our economy for this. It's fine
Right, and then we're gonna skip and then that will raise him a little bit
Play only one. Oh, we've lost
We just need to go for aces
He says yep aces
He says
Shit well, we've only got one hand
Shopping the day, I don't know who got it. I don't think so
Oh my god buy a freaking ball here. Whoa not good
We need we need improvements right now
Right now we need improvements
We need improvements right now
I think raised fist
We're gonna swap you out for free
Yeah, sorry you're we're trying with you, but you're not doing enough
Um
We're
We're needing to level him up. He's gonna come in clutch over time as well
I
I know we need to skip packs. I know
I should maybe level up four of a kind five of a kind later do
I know I should try and hold on to economy, but we're trying to catch up with the demands
Of the game right now and it's not doing well
I
1.5 I think
I think yes for 1.5 on something something's gonna get swapped out for a 1.5
What are you cards played previously or debuffed? Okay lucky me wait, so don't play my fucking aces
Uh three of a kind I could test out. I am not obviously I don't have a I could discard though for an ace
Oh
We leveled up ten wait hold on let's check three of a kind is like a thousand
And then two pairs what's four of a kind four of a kind
Is weaker so three of a kind for now
And then another three of a kind
Four of a kind fives they're weaker though
So
Wait, but this will let me level up four of a kind which I want for the aces because I'm going to keep duplicating the aces
Yes
I would like to duplicate the aces
Wait what?
Oh no
Oh no, wait what?
Oh
Oh no
I should have used the three of a kind sorry
I messed that up. Oh, I thought maybe we could have had that. Oh, we got joker unlock
Sell a total of 50 cards upgrade the
Upgrade the level of the first discarded poker hand each round
interesting
Oh
Chat didn't math I didn't math either. So the high table scammed you exactly
Not discovered purchaser use this card in an unceded run to learn what it does. I like that
We messed up. No, it's okay. I actually thought that was the best choice because I would have got two
um
Two upgrades for four of a pair and because I've been going crazy on the aces that actually would have came in quite well
Um, I am going to redirect into yumi plus girl
Um because
I am going to upload everyone's highlights
From debut
So I hope you're ready to look at them. So even though the girls are offline. It doesn't count. Okay
Oh meadow's doing a zomboid meadow plays zomboid
I remember trying to play that and oh lord
I
Zura is taking today off question mark. Hold on. Azura do they
Is she definitely taking today off or is she about to go alive?
Whoa, oh that's another three hours away
Azura forgive me, but I need to upload all your videos
Um, okay, apparently zura is coming up in three hours for anyone who is lurking in the shadows
I am going to go off because I'm going to make some ASMR videos in the background
I'm going to upload the girls highlight reels and please do check them out when you see them drop
Thank you so so much for keeping me company. I do understand. I was supposed to play runescape endurance
Um, that will come later. We are very close to 99. I think one more endurance and we're at 99
Um tomorrow for me is the binding of Isaac
We're going to try and win on an eden run and I can show you my save file and how much progress I've made in it
Um
And we might try a lily's greed mode. I enjoy greed mode seems like not everyone enjoys it
But lily's greed mode is super duper easy. She's watch me not even win a game tomorrow
Um, and then we're doing a watch along of the first a membership watch along my apologies of the first
iron man
um, so do grab iron man movie if you can via your streaming service that you pay for and
Uh, and that is the on tondra for anyone who wasn't here right at the start of stream
Um, I do have my schedule as I am looking for right this very second
Of course, I can't see it so that would be too easy
Where is it?
Stream la movie
In game in game png. Oh, here we go cancel. Where are you?
There we go for those of you who weren't at the very start. This is what I'm getting up to next week
Um, I'm having shorter streams. There's no endurance stream planned unless you count
Um, apparently spirals play time is like
Five hours straight is five hours as well. So if you want to count those as endurance, you're more than welcome to
Um, I just burped when I said in there
I'm also playing the jelly bean game is my stream snipe game. So you're more than welcome to join me
And downloading fall guys. Um, it's a hoot and a holler
Uh, I may have to beg you guys to let me into the second round again
Um, but yes, please don't be afraid to
Download fall guys and stream snipe me. I will tell you the code everything will be all good
And we'll have an amazing time. I will update everyone's channel very shortly
Um, there's no gamble planned for next week. I can't believe it. No gamble
Um cameo, we're gonna play which is a childhood game
We're gonna do a member script writing stream of a alternative script
But I'm going to do a public writing ASMR collabs. I'm going to do one-on-one ASMR collabs with everyone in velour
Um, and I I'm going to write it live and you can suggest what you want us to say. Okay
I gambled the house and I won a cockroach
honestly, um
and
the members streams
We've got a script writing
We've got a watch long of night at the museum, which is like this comedy and it had the
I've not seen it in many a year many a year indeed
There's a members ASMR stream and then there's a members video game. It's not gonna be that long the members video game. I'm just gonna
Just gonna talk about it and why I like the game. We'll play it for a little bit
But I'll kind of dive in a bit more why we're doing 60 seconds. Um
But yeah, uh nice stacked week, uh, not many
Endurances so for those of you who are perishing at the thought of an endurance stream
You're safe. Uh, and the week after follows, uh, my dad is here
Um, so I'll keep you up to date with like his sleep schedule
Um, because I don't know if I'm gonna have to be like, hi guys
I can't do ASMR because my dad is snoring in the background. Yay
So hang tight on the ASMR streams for now. I I
I definitely would urge you to enjoy the ASMR streams for next week
If you're available to come see them
Because there might be a three week break due to my dad snoring and having the loudest snore in all of the world
um
The he is literally the loudest snore ever. It's like the kind of snore like not even the
Um, and I don't want that in the back of oh, where did that go?
Oh, and also if you missed it, um, we also decided on the pose that I'm being drawn pregnant with you
Which is the third pose. Yippee
unanimously everyone voted for pose three, which is so cute
So, uh, yeah pregnant with you ASMR coming to a subscription box near you
Please like and subscribe. Oh, I finally did it. I'm a real content creator
I finally said like and subscribe took me long enough. That's the first time I've said it this week probably
um
But yes, I my ego is prego with you and we'll write the ASMR together and it's gonna be so cute and
All of that jazz. I know it's cursed ASMR. Don't care. Love it. I like pursuing my weird dream. Don't forget to hit that bell
Yeah, yeah, that's right. Oh, I just like the stream. Oh, yeah, I like the stream all over
Um, I think I have a new short out as well. If I'm not mistaken. Oh, uh, something went wrong
Oh, I've been kicked out of my youtube account. Wow, google. Can you please relax?
Holy moly. Well, good thing
I don't need to be signed in in order to search if my youtube channel at least
There might be a new short. Give me a second. Just type it in there
Uh, let's see. Uh, staroni cuttles. Let's see if there was one or not. I can't remember. Holy moly
I'm almost at 9 000 subscribers. I only have freaking two ASMR's
Oh my gosh. Oh, I do
God my voice is very, uh, unique. Let's just say that there you go. I do have a new short out
It's me, uh, lusting over sheeby's design
Uh, because of how good it is. Uh, it's just a short little highlight. Nothing major
So, you know, if you want to watch it leave a little like uh, it's literally 10 seconds and it makes all the difference
Uh, the the ride never ends staroni. Rob, I'm literally what?
How many?
I the debt is about to be seven ASMR videos
And I'm only two ahead right now and I just uploaded the uh, the ear cleaning one
Which was a hoot and a holler. My debt grows literally just as it does in
Uh, baltro. My debt is still continuing to grow. Hmm
Hmm
Um
Wait, this is very unique. You will get there. Don't worry. Your shorts are the best. Yeah
Aesthetic literally aesthetics. No one can tell. Oh she beats it. Nope
Emmy's up
Oh, but I see up
Azur is too up
Mary up. No
No
No is my response
That's it. That's all you're getting at
Nope, don't want to hear it. What about the gamba audio? Oh, no
Uh, that's going to be a bit in the future
Uh, for anyone who watched they want to start your own vtuber agency
If you pause um at the scene where a reference sheet is going in the bin
You can see my old reference sheet. Um, it is very true
That's a little behind the scenes if you saw that chart. Um, I got reference sheets for everyone
But they ended up coming out incorrect
So I had to get new ones made and I ended up spending a lot of money
And it was a bit of a waste
But hey, you you live and you learn you I learned so much from uh doing gen one
But if you pause on that chart, you can literally see my old reference sheet and the back panels
I can actually show you the
Okay, sorry
You see the back panel ones you see, um, so you know how I have the green front panely ones
The back panel ones
Uh, we're actually designed to be brown to match my yukata, but uh, we ended up
Um changing it because it looked a bit
Uh unique on content juice. I never show this. No wonder I never show this that is outrageous
Who designed that?
Hey
It's outrageous. I can't believe I even possible
Anyway, anyway
Anyway, bikini stream one
Yes, we'll have to find an alternative. Yes, just finished the john wick vaude. Uh, yeah an absolute shambles
That's why we're gambin today, but please don't worry if you had enough of beltro
Don't worry. I'm taking a pause on beltro next week. You don't have to worry. It's not coming up again
Does your avatar have a backside too? No, I freaking saw those vtuber models. Sorry. I'm itch am Ible
I saw those vtuber models where it does like the the butt
um
and
and what
um, I wanted to get it, but I was well
YouTube's already put me on a warning so I'm trying to behave as best as I can
So I don't but mommies grippers. Yes, those are my grippers my french tip manicure pedicure
um, I
I'm going to redirect into the lovely mero who's playing project zomboid. I had no idea
You want a backside of your model show off the huge dumpy?
Honestly, there would be so much on show. I couldn't get away with it because the back of my design
Well, I guess it's like a frilly dress
But I guess it's not too bad
You should think about hardcore henry for a watch along if you're into action movies
But filmed entirely in first person. So if you're bad with motion sickness, no, I actually don't get motion sickness
Apparently azura and mercy do I did not realize how common motion sickness in videos games were
I
I said, uh, this I guess this is just ignorance, but because I don't know better
um
I'm just like, oh, it's not a problem for me. So why would it be a problem for the masses?
Oh, um
Buckshot really it's also going to be multiplayer soon tm. I don't know when it drops
But when it does drop don't be surprised if there's collapse coming up
um
That's a good movie. Yeah the dumpy
All right, I won't steal too much more of your time because the girls are probably waiting on their highlight reels going up
So thank you so so much for keeping me company. I appreciate it greatly. I'll see you tomorrow for a binding of isaac
I get to nerd out about binding of isaac and before you're like, oh, do you know every single item and what it does?
No, I've not even unlocked every single item, but the game the binding of isaac
repentance
Uh dlc, whatever you want to call it. Um, I am going to show you my progress because in november the game goes multiplayer
We are very likely wildcard. Uh, we are very likely to play multiplayer for quite a few days
Uh, I don't even know if greed mode multiplayer is possible. That would be hilarious. How like crazy it gets
Um, can't wait for the highlights to go up. Yeah, thank you
I completely messed up my stream. My music was too loud. So the guy that edited it tried to like reduce the music
But my voice sounds a bit funny. Um, but it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
It tried his best editor tried his best. Um
But thank you all so much. I'm going to be directing tomorrow
Please be came tomorrow. Um, she's a sweetheart and for any bleeding hearts zura is up in t minus three hours
I repeat t minus three hours, but please do look for the highlight videos that are going to go out on the channels
Very why did I just get bigger?
Uh, well that was a bit startling if i'm honest, but hey, oh, uh, thank you so so much and I will see you
tomorrow for
Eden run not
No elden ring. We're taking a pause on the injurances for a bit. Okay. Thank you so so much. I'll see you tomorrow. Bye. Bye
Bye we flings
Pucker your lips right now
Bye-bye be nice tomorrow. Okay. Bye